we're like welcome to the eye Lord
podcast episode number eight fool and
this is the e3 2017 prediction series
the final chapter and Microsoft is up to
bat and we have saved the very best for
last as most of you already aware the
iron Lords are multi-platform
all multi-platform holders however Xbox
is our console of preference and today
it is an honor to have Xbox from royalty
at the roundtable I want to start by
introducing the Lord I met in the flesh
and III 2015 I have been following his
career up for some time he is a fixture
in the Xbox community produces extremely
high quality content and outside of my
partner Lord addict is one of the main
reasons I became inspired to jump into
the realm of the Lords in this gaming
community
he always represents his viewpoints in a
positive balance and concise manner it's
definitely a pillar in these Xbox
streets with his insightful interviews
with various members of the gaming
industry introducing the creator of the
inner circle podcast the host of super
pod shots and the last son of Planet
Xbox mommy Kor ex kal-el is in the
building how are you doing service bro
that is the most incredible introduction
I've ever seen like my entire life he's
always like yeah he's always like you
need to have your inch I was more like
my dog no one can have your intro not
done we got the ball bosses we got a
show respect my god I know if I can live
up to that expectation on the show at
this point I do have to appreciate that
man hey what's going on everybody thank
you for inviting me on higher/lower
podcast man I'm just grateful to be here
continuously try to be a voice for the
Xbox community try to be a positive spot
for people to come listen to so I'm
excited to be on today a man Tim dog I
ever spoke to Tim in a minute my man Tim
dog was on so I'm excited to chat with
everybody in being a chat with you guys
absolutely an absolute pleasure man
always a pleasure to have you in the
building so we don't get this thing
going
and of course my second guess no
stranger to the ILP in the Xbox
community he's always supported us from
day one even back when we were primarily
just a destiny focus podcast with the
intervention series this Lord is
arguably the most passionate Xbox gamer
I know and like my previous guests it's
always a pleasure to running to them
each and every e3 and every Microsoft
function he is a panelist for a few
prominent Xbox podcasts including my
guys over there at txr and it's passion
for the brand is evident in everything
he does introducing fellow Xbox fan
fellow met fan fellow Conor McGregor's
through the beat Floyd Mayweather yeah
and the man puts the beasts fire in 4k
Scorpio bang I love it
Lord Shiv dog how we doing sir wow wow
that's that's awesome thank you for that
insane intro oh thank you no I'm happy
to be here man this is this is what it's
all about we're getting close and uh
really thanks for the words and wow I
was feeling like Conor McGregor was like
I was like I felt like you two like in
the middle of the Ring wow I couldn't
believe you said that you think you
could beat him listen look Kings gonna
smack me right now I really did donate
anything you said honey mommy's Idol but
I had I had to throw the chili throw
some sauce on well I'm happy to be here
thank you so much for having me
absolutely miss a pleasure and of course
we have usual rustic suspects at the
round table and I got the cook my
co-host with the coat most the non agro
gamer himself my man Lord addict how are
we doing sir what's going on you guys
nice nice nice in the building all
enthusiastic and of course we got the
most technical gaming Lord solo gamer
who lives for the solo single player
experience no longer the luminaries on
twitter now y'all
mom hair-loss sovereign how are we doing
sir doing well doing well man excited
man e3 is two weeks away I am chomping
at the bit don't man oh yeah we hide we
hide right now playing destiny and clean
I know we talked about that we talked
about that you definitely shading your
single-player Monica
I'll of course excess gamer oh god who
demands nothing less than the premium
experience oh love it oh look how we
doing sir what's going on everyone glad
to be here this weekend like we fairly
got two weeks to go baby's beautiful
California here we come
definitely definitely man so hype um you
know obviously this is a big show and I
really appreciate the guests coming
through and you're just real quick just
want to go through everybody um start
with our Lord cow Oh what's everybody
been playing you know what's been
playing this week I know we got lost
everyone's busy with functions and stuff
uh locality what you been playing this
week video I've been uh I've been
playing some i testing out some
overwatch you know i spots got some good
deals going on games with gold I I was
contemplating trying to figure out which
game I wanted to get between mafia to be
entitled for Towanda picking up Titan
for two and their choice um I got a Mass
Effect I just picked up Mass Effect as
well some I'm kind of in a rotation
between those three games right now
still down Rudy's on the floor right now
nice nice
and Noah Tim go what have you been
playing spin on your gaming radar
I've been playing I just started I
played rhyme which learn beautiful game
um but it's kind of kind of like the
games have been playing a lot like it
has some elements of nuuma I don't know
if you guys remember that game yeah yeah
it has some elements it's it's a pretty
game arm I like it but I've been really
enjoying um well I played it the little
that I played it was Friday the 13th
Oh screaming at last um it's a fun game
it's a social game there are a lot of
issues there are a lot of things that
people hate about this game and they
will just hate it but they'll still play
it it's a weird game um
I'm enjoying it a lot i just recommend
if you're going to play don't even try
to do a auto-connect just find friends
call up your friend you know cuz if you
could do a private match you can get it
goin and it's worth if there's some
crazy moments in it like yesterday I was
killed in and I was in the house I saw
Jason I try to go in the bathroom and I
closed the door in front of me instead
of him back like to close it and Jason
hitting you in an axe and killed me and
broke he killed me through the door I
wish she killed through the door I was
uh I was in a bar I was in a party with
one of my friends and he was Jason and I
wasn't in the game and I'm like and I
hear so it's like I had these hit this
headset on and here's someone like
panicking because you have to hold your
breath if you're under the bed or
anything and I'm like there's someone
around you man he's looking around he
starts taking the axe through cabinets
start taking the axe through like walls
and [ __ ] and then he was like maybe the
bed and all you see is him rape the bed
up and they just start going to the town
with this axe on this dude Wow so the to
the trick a Latino is that um you have
to kind of do private matches to get it
going I think here there were some
issues yeah that's all don't even try
connecting just get I think you should
get for this I think you could play a
minimum of four not really sure we
started with six because I thought you
had to have the full eight but that's
not true so you could you could have you
can have like I guess six ones Jason
another five are um but yeah that's the
only way to go and typically go with
whoever has the best connection which is
gonna host you know well you know that
basically if you're gonna do it that way
uh so I you know III like I said I can't
really recommend it but it's weird game
if you love Jason you'll be happy you
because I see the potential in it it is
just like I love I love the premise I
just was hoping to execute me better but
if they fix the issue it could be fun
it's a shame that came out with issues
because it would have been a very fun
game mmm nice so blood addict what have
you been playing I've been playing Halo
Wars too and Friday 13 that is all cuz
I'm still waiting on my xbox
I know hopefully Xbox support it
wouldn't let me 30th to the first Jesus
ah
and it was just the UH they did identify
with Yeshua no it just said yo shits on
your way damn well alright
Louis of it was the good OG but you can
play a little bit of destiny man Charlie
trying to get my light up yeah I was
socializing you come up for his list and
you guys run prison of elders and some
story missions and stuff yet trying to
get that light up to see if I could try
my first uh my first raid and see how I
fare at that um then besides that just
some just switch man um playing some
more thumper getting my ass kicked by
thumper um a little more NBA playgrounds
and an arms man the arms test punch was
great it really sold me on the game so
yes I'm excited for that
but you on that were definitely
definitely a lot of potential with that
more than I expected and on given lord
King what have you been up to in these
game streets I've been dipping in
dodging flipping and getting all over
the place this is really crazy to be
honest with you I've been playing a
little bit of Wii U because I got this
elder for the Wii U came in so I set
that up for my son uh and my playstation
zero rising dawn and you know up in VR
and heavy with them
speaking of the number shout out to the
to the real thumper that's inside that
place yeah get that one really amazed at
the game because it's really good um
I've even touched my Vita yesterday
which was crazy
LeBron um I saw I saw the games there
and they're Cali love you know that
their flight and I'm like man I'm I got
to snatch you up with a couple of these
games I got here because the library was
very extensive and very
to be honest with you um and you know
you know my switch on Xbox Oh Oh game
pass Oh I can't see too much about that
but man oh man
I know man oh man we're gonna get into
that later
no doubt cool cool it hits me like I'm
you know here yeah it's been a little
bit of a mixed week I've been on I did
the arms test punch like Lord sovereign
was talking about had a lot of fun with
that I mean every time I see that game I
was just like I just thought it was a
complete motion control joke when I
first started announced in each like
Nintendo Direct and each subsequent you
know gameplay showing I get more excited
but yeah they might have something on
the hair so that I did it with regular
controls without motion had a great time
um this week as far as Xbox has been all
destiny I've been in my raid mode that
my team is back together channel 5 and
we're doing weekly raids and you know
it's been fun just carrying people
through and when the future rate stuff
like that
everybody's hide for destiny too so we
just been kind of in that mindset yeah
what yeah lucky is dealing us he sent me
that message it's like you did get your
xbox back we need you with these right
yeah we miss you very busy man lord King
Mary we miss you guys
oh yeah do something ever I'm a baby
okay cool cool cuz it's like yes we we
have some people it's been hard to drag
through the other person fits the back
put people in our backpacks well it's
been fun but I want to get this going I
want to do a different approach this
time for the show obviously we have Xbox
royalty in the building is kind of like
I want to talk about it's kind of like
the state of Xbox right now so you're
gonna bring the Xbox mob bosses you know
cuz right now a lot of the community
feels Xbox is in a crisis you know and I
already obviously the climate has been
low rough if you've been the next box
fan you know last couple of months I
mean obviously the dominance of Sony IPs
you got the I heard me talking about
arms and the switch and the rise of the
switch and I mean the numbers are there
obviously selling like hotcakes they're
doing very well right now and what I
wanted to start with the first topic is
primarily the importance of this e3 and
specifically pertaining to Phil
legacy and what I want to start to want
to have this set off with with more cow
because I've seen him comment on some
things you know that I kind of feel very
strongly with and I agree with him as
far as you know the mindset of Microsoft
at this point specifically filming where
it's coming from and the things he is
doing and things he's not doing so lord
cow I want to set it off with you first
I start about the state of the community
and also how important this thing is to
East III as DeSales legacy I mean I
think for the hardcore the hardcore base
no one is really bothered by it honestly
you have some people who are a bit
concerned because of all the third party
deals and stuff like that um I tried to
bring levity to it with a tweet here and
there about how you know Microsoft's you
can tell Microsoft is trying to refocus
first party they took a couple LS over
the last year and some change you know
the loss of two studios in press play
and uh lion head and then fable
cancellation scale bounds cancellation
that kind of hurt them just a bit so
people are be concerned and I and all in
all honesty I didn't like last year's e3
from Microsoft because one here's the
thing and in the biggest difference
between last year and this year is when
like the end of May hit so much stuff
got leaked so when I went to the show
were living I knew everything right so I
saw everything and then a show stuff
from the previous year that we had
already seen our video wasn't impress
had it not been for the reveal of the
Xbox one s and Scorpio that show to me
would have been that would have been a
big L in my opinion I'm saying because
Sony came out to show some really good
quality title stuff I didn't see before
like days gone or gameplay like full
gameplay of horizon zero dawn like
Spider Man like those were major the
remains or show offs in my opinion so I
really wasn't blown away by it
but and then you come out early this
year you have all the issues with scale
about cancellation you got a week lineup
just about there's no knock on phantom
dust there's no knock over two events
but you know original Xbox
honey like a rigid I need is not
knocking nobody's door down you don't
I'm saying so for Microsoft but they
have to come out and do is show that the
games that they're gonna be producing
work and that they're going to release
the share to me the most exciting game I
know a lot of people don't think this
way but to me the most exciting game
they can possibly show besides a new
reveal of something is crackdown and the
reason why I'm saying that is because I
try to give perspective that you have
the original developer of crackdown work
on the game who's also the father of
grand theft auto you can produce
anything similar to a mix of Grand Theft
Auto and infamous and I know that's a
big jump but if you can give me the
mission based story base side and single
player with crackdown like you were
doing Grand Theft Auto in an open-world
city driving around going mission by
mission try and take out some big boss
and maybe the boss is a super-powered as
well and then on the flipside and
multiplayer you have all these super
heroes running around leaping from
buildings crumbling all over the entire
city bullets flying explosions going you
happen car transforms you're driving
down the bridge the bridge blows up you
hop out the car jump out if you can make
it that intense that exciting with that
many people on screen plus the
destruction the entire city is
destructible and if you have a revival
of a franchise that can really inspire a
lot of people to hop on xbox but they
really need to be able to show that
they're going to produce some quality
titles that the future looks bright that
is not dying off because a lot of people
think it is
and I really think that's what their
focuses that's why I said third parties
don't worry about third party deals
ideally that [ __ ] in like resourceful
Microsoft needs to focus on first party
and be building brand trust I do think
it's funny how people for years said
Microsoft needs to stop worrying so much
about third party they back off the
marketing goes a little bit they're like
Microsoft needs more market you know
okay go
djenka it it's the perception you look
at 360 360 literally released like the
last couple years of 360 you had like a
bunch of halos a bunch of fours it's
nothing really new but you had caught
you had Cod you had Cod DLC I grant the
board over at the portal DLC oh that
definitely carry a whole system that's
what I'm saying and reception was that
micro sex box had mad games even if the
games came to Sony late they ran better
third party wise and then you had all
these time exclusives in time DLC so it
really worked out for them but long term
it didn't help first party and that's
why Sony has this unbreakable bond with
fans is because it's not that it's not
that they have a game that's like
destroying sales but you have all these
niche gamers that can only get these
games on this console and that a dram
and that's basically what it is it adds
up Microsoft has to figure out a way to
get these little small pockets of gamers
where they can only get these games on
xbox and then those sales will add up
over time hey I just want one question
with off to uh Norton in reference to
what you said Cal like what do you feel
like as far as people I know we're going
to get into the marketing deals a little
bit with the next I don't want to spill
too much into it but almost with the
mindset of people saying that like maybe
Phil is not being aggressive enough in a
war that he necessarily need to win
obviously you know like you said
hardcore fans really you know the most
part are not concerned about it but to
the casual sometimes the perception is
that Microsoft is not trying and then
you have like things like Sony out here
you know obviously they're winning the
NPD the sales stuff like that and yeah
obviously the switch and stuff like that
so what do you say to those who really
feel that maybe Phil's approach in his
attitude you know is just maybe too
laid-back you know I mean I know I know
exactly what you're saying I think that
um Phil first of all Phil's been in the
game for a long time um he's a PC gamer
and you know he's a he's a really good
guy to industry it's the reason why
everybody when he became the head of
Xbox praised him you know praises this
was a great decision when Don Mattrick
stepped out that says a lot about the
industry but you gotta know
yeah I mean uh yeah he got pushed out
and when they may feel Spencer the boss
you know you know you got Sony Nintendo
or everybody's congratulating him and
this is a great decision it's a great
move that says a lot um but what I would
like to see more from Phil is fire and
more as a console gamer this as a
console onion not the only gamer but as
a constable gamer I would like to see
more fire from them and I know they got
the fan fest thing and they do all that
stuff like that but sometimes the same
thing perception is everything I've seen
recently somebody asks him a question
about mixer and whether or not he wanted
to bring it to ps4 he said yes and in my
opinion that's that's something that you
have built on your platform and don't
get me wrong is great for gaming is
great for the industry but at the same
time that's an advantage for you know
uh-huh I don't view it that way is he's
going that a twitch you understand what
the mixer so twitches on everybody's
platform what he wants it to be is the
same thing is twitch that it's available
on everybody's platform and everybody
gets a chance to use it and everybody
gets a chance to broadcast it and you
know what they already know that the
PlayStation can't broadcast in 4k so
it's a very antenna so you can have the
substandard thing on that system and
that's fantastic but what he's going at
and he's looking at he's playing chess
so he's looking at a bigger picture you
know not to say that your point is
invalid your point is valid but he has
to make it appeal to everyone to bring
everyone in because if somebody says
yeah I got mix over here well how come
it looks so much better on that Xbox oh
they do 4k oh really
and I don't bring them over I understand
that but I'm talking you're looking at
long term now don't get me wrong
obviously it's you you bought this
company you spit a lot of money on it
you want to recoup a lot of money on it
and I understand that 100% obviously
you're going to have to go
multi-platform in order to even
challenge twitch which is practically on
everything you have saying so I get that
I get that but at the same time
you come out with some type of exclusive
um feature sets or something like that
it's another reason why somebody may
choose PlayStation over exponent you can
save that for now but when ps5 comes out
it mixture has to upgrade itself for ps5
and the things running on mixer is
actually better on ps5 than Scorpio then
you're at a disadvantage once again with
your own product so for me it's not so
much it's not even so much the mixer
thing but it's just more of I would like
to see more focus on the Xbox gamer and
not so much focused on everybody all the
time I want to get up I feel I feel
you're saying I want to get to go get
this die for a spin as well we gonna
jump back on that point cuz I know where
you go with that guy Tim don't go there
sir you know I know you've been hearing
a lot of a concern at the roundtable or
upset I've got a listen to everything
who said the do you think that is we're
going to talk about it and if you in the
next section but you see the deals and
you see the cross-cutting moves mm-hmm
you see you see everything that's going
on you see them missing out on games
like lawbreaker
okay you see what Phil says basically no
marketing nothing they basically you
know healy said that's not in our vision
but he said first party is in their
vision right so for me it's and I think
a lot of Xbox fans it's going to be put
up or shut up
you you three years in now okay um not
to see you start to see some growth in
that area since you've been talking in
it about it and you you have to show it
so at e3 is it is a critical III now I
think it might be light but the fact is
is that they have to give us that vote
of confidence because that's the vote of
confidence that thing every Xbox fan is
worried about right now they don't want
it to become a steam they don't want it
to become strictly a service
linguo they want them to create games
create games I cracked-out create games
like wanna break they we've grown up
being you know that's a part of the deal
so I fear sometimes that like there is
no movement in the first part of the
department they're not spending money
anywhere they're just saying they're not
saying okay we're gonna put it here but
then if they don't show it what are they
really doing with that money I do feel
that Microsoft is Ochs I think that I
think Meyerson is Phil's boss so I think
that Meyerson might be a guy numbers
type guy that just keeps trying to cut
but mine is that you're gonna have come
to a point where you say I got a making
we gotta be real about it and if you're
not then you're gonna lose guys like me
in the hardcore and that is what you do
not want to do we want the full cake you
got everything there you have Scorpio
you built it you gotta make games that's
not that's that's that's the way I feel
personal I don't respond about once you
start losing your hardcore then then
stuff goes downhill from there doc know
what lost Tov I wouldn't get your a
feedback on this as far as just the
whole perception of Phil right now his
legacy
coming into this III wait where you at
with this loss um um I've always been of
the mind that when you look at I always
felt that Xbox no matter what they did
on worldwide level as much as I love
Xbox as much as that's my platform of
choice on a worldwide level it was never
ever going to be what a PlayStation is
it just doesn't have the foothold
throughout the world so my feeling for
the for the system is that I've always
wanted it to be the best place to play
third parties always win the power
conversation and then and then give me
some interesting first parties um and
I'd obviously expand upon the big
pillars that you have already in terms
of that doesn't necessarily have to be
the mind-blowing stuff that you get you
know I don't know a dog or something
like that but just something to
differentiate the system now I
understand I understand what what Tim
dog is saying I understand what Kalla
saying into
like the first parties is very important
give me a real reason to come to this
system and make it be a differentiated
from what PlayStation is I think the
position that they're in and what feels
uh what what Phil's thinking is moving
forward is I have to try to make this
system as appealing to the general
consumer as possible and by doing I
understand the games are super important
but of building up a game building up a
franchise that is a multi-year
multi-million dollar endeavor that
doesn't always pay off and it's a tongue
thing that they've had tough luck in
that regard where things they've
invested in haven't paid off and also
and also they victimized themselves also
because what they've done is they
haven't shown the confidence in certain
IP to take again take a game that's a
seven and say you know we're gonna build
on this mm-hmm
when they market they drop it they say
that you know that's it now it didn't do
what we needed it to do next and by
doing that obviously your your your core
loses confidence in you but I think
Phil's thinking moving forward is I have
to make the console as gamer friendly
moving forward with the services they
provide and his hope in doing that when
you talk about game past when you talk
about things to make just make the
entire ecosystem more appealing to the
average consumer and hopefully that
brings people in which again which would
give the number crunchers the confidence
to put more money into the single-player
stuff and give us more so it's just one
of those things where it's like I
understand the nice guy persona thing
and I understand but build you know
let's be clear he's been in this
business a long time he's a shark he's a
shark he just come off that way um he's
he fully understands what he's doing and
at the end of the day we don't know how
that's gonna pan out but I understand
him trying to make the system you know
with things like game pass with things
like justjust other backward
compatibility stuff just making it more
and more appealing to gamers so that at
the end of the day they have that base
there
they can say okay now we're willing to
invest more in the first party I
understand it's a hundred percent
important but I think create creating
the platform creating the best platform
to be on I think is his goal right now
yes what you said it took some good
points here look look King I know quite
a bit let me let me let you get some oh
yeah what everyone a table to flesh out
the thoughts and you know I'm have room
to brief on any thoughts and you know
everybody thoughts is very valid i've
always equated Microsoft for get trying
to gain ground in a place where
PlayStation yanked the throne away from
Nintendo they were bruised by Nintendo
the yank the throne away from Nintendo
and we viewed PlayStation as the place
to go to play games and was cool now we
talking PlayStation wondering that the
whole yes yeah that's good station one
for the CD correct yes so well you know
and from there on they built they built
they did constantly were the champions
in that realm until you know Microsoft
came in and you know that's because of
the demise of Sega so it always seemed
like it was a rainstorm outside a
Microsoft is always trying to start a
fire try to get it going
some days it is stopped raining and the
Sun is shine on us and we can cook and
it was fantastic Microsoft we get it
going but right now it seems like it's a
downpour and they're trying to get this
spark going to try to get this fire
going
I don't think Scorpios such that fire
and here's why just just like Cal said
last year's e3 was a semi disappointment
and the point that we knew everything
going in right and you know we just
wanted to see more of stuff and the
stuff that we did get excited about
it's like scalebound got canceled so
okay you put out a system just Xbox 1s
is fantastic it's nice and you're coming
out with Scorpio now you're going to
have the narrative that you're bigger
stronger better and you want those
third-party games to run better on your
system we always
that advantage and that was fantastic
but that's going to be short-lived with
the PlayStation 5 will come out at some
point in time again with you back at
that narrative what I've seen and you
know we'll get into a later segment is
the direction microsoft is going in I
think Cal or Tim dog brought up the fact
that they don't want it to become a
service and what I've noticed is it's
going that way
whoo you know um we're going to do these
mid for system refresh is that's nice
that backwardly compatible stuff this
stuff has to concern you because they
are backwards compatible with the Xbox
one games all the way up right ok so now
that they have broken that threshold and
they can offer these games as a service
Hummer how can we figure this price out
when he says stuff like he wants the
mixer on PlayStation you know like
really no not fair that so you know as
Xbox commands are we feeling when when
Phil makes these kind of statements no
ok ok no not at all
I'm not feeling it at all listen
PlayStation is a hardware company period
right their DNA is hardware they make
nice TVs to make the Walkman they make
the PlayStation when Nintendo screwed
them they like they couldn't make a
system you understand oh that's ok let's
go make a system we don't know anything
about games but we're going to learn
along the way and that's the and they're
not knowing how to make games allows
them to purchase little developers along
the way to produce games they make great
systems games come to Microsoft is a
software company and the essence is
software they will always revert back to
the DNA and if the fear is that they're
going to turn it to a streamer system
like Netflix because they look at a
billion dollar company like Netflix it
doesn't have to put out a drop of
hardware and it's just
100% recouping what happens that they
can develop games and have it on a
system on on on their software without
putting out hardware so pretty much you
feel like they're looking at that model
it's things they want to kind of
imitating and get going you know as far
as on the Xbox platform yeah look at the
climate I see yeah okay
Lord addict I want you to get an
intrical unless somebody something like
callous might want to jump in real quick
yeah let me just I just want to run just
so that um with the with the host with
the whole sub situation mmm Microsoft I
don't think Microsoft will stop to
producing hardware and the reason why I
don't think Microsoft will stop
producing hardware is because of the
simple fact that there's certain things
you can do with hardware in a certain
things you could do with software that
you know that you can control compared
to just say putting it in a TV as a
service or doing things like that you
know you make money off of these
controllers that they produce these
accessories that they produce there's a
lot of money in that but also what these
subs do is it gives them cushion so when
we talk about games like quantum break
or sunset overdrive that may not pan out
the way they may have expected it to
they got money to fall back on I think
this is more of as a security situation
before Microsoft that it is a service
situation for Microsoft had a
conversation with the father of Xbox
Seamus blackly Seamus can't want to show
shot the Seamus he came on a show we
talked a bit about you know do
controller and Microsoft and stuff but
he gave me some great insight on um the
thought process of being in charge of
Xbox and how you have to deal with the
board because I think people lose sight
that Bill and that team has to deal with
the board and you try to get money to
make games you got to go through the
board you know when you're gonna get
your cut so if the games you're
producing are making that bread back why
would the board continue to give you
money you don't say no that's all valid
points you're talking from a strictly
business standpoint huge right right
that's each point so why some happening
is they produce Scorpio Scorpio allows
filled with interim I'll say hey I got a
new console
I mean bread yeah honey baby girl he ask
you a question and I think it's all
valid I do think that and I've always
said the 2018 will be the true tailgate
fine I agree if you're playing around
that oh yes do you think that's okay to
deal with us is like is Scorpio and a
good price point enough to not make you
jump off like if they have a really
light III and they have but they're very
strong on Scorpio they have a good price
point is that enough or is that okay to
you as a consumer do you think that do
you think that maybe they should even
start to try to invest now or they think
that they have to wait because I feel
exactly like you do I feel they have to
see what Scorpio does Scorpio produces
then Phil can say hey I want this I want
that you got it
I think that when it comes to the whole
you know perspective on what when do
they need a show stuff it's not a matter
if if they have something it's one
they're going to show it and I think
with all this this publicity going on
that they got nothing I do think that
they need to show a couple games from
2018 they need to show games from 2018
but not 2018 winter write something that
would that's gonna be in the tangible
future right
so something that we gonna get in 2017
as well as 20 like early 2018 don't
you're gonna get in fall you don't know
what you're gonna get next year that's
what you know as a surprise for early
the one thing Microsoft has a problem
with is putting out games in the second
and first quarter in finish what they
have this fall this holiday which is
what we already knows you know whether
it see if these crackdown steady the
cave four to seven and maybe some other
surprise game +33 surprising IPS and
drops early 2018 then you got something
but it has to be it has to be major has
to be surprising it has to be major and
I gotcha
oh you finish what you're
you know yeah I mean I'm pretty much I'm
done but I'm doing cuz I want any time a
question I feel like the biggest the
biggest issue they have and I feel like
this particular issue you know all their
problems of Microsoft draws down to this
issue and it's releasing games at the
wrong time like they they have an
obsession we're releasing the holidays
and yet Oh games like sunset overdrive
have a hard time controlling game so
that in turns makes it so you know the
cells are exactly where they should be
then you know it's like a domino effect
they get back to Microsoft Microsoft
like look we gave you so X amount of
money you made sunset and we didn't get
the return back and then you know but if
that would have been launched like you
know in the fall not the fall like the
spring March
Yoji early resident thing Sony does very
well honestly I don't think it's fun
yeah it cap now I'm sorry I mean to cut
you up go ahead finish up no I'm just
I'm just kind of piggybacking off Lord
at exploit which is that I think that's
something that you know Microsoft needs
to improve upon because I do remember
certain times when they were releases
like a sunset overdrive or even that you
know halo where it's very close to the
call of duty release and it's just like
you can't do that then you have to allow
the title to breve and I understand
sometimes from a holiday perspective
they look at it where you know Black
Friday you have all those deals all
those sales and you can kind of group
things up but sometimes I feel that
leaves the IP to die and not flourish
properly not obviously each I can fall
in exactly I mean was a billion dollar
know exactly but I just look at like
that and I just think it's such a shame
you know but what's that but it's like I
said though I think you know there's a
lot of issues when it comes to the you
know Microsoft over the years you could
say what you want about them you could
say they don't have a lot of games they
have probably one of the most iconic
brands in game besides the PlayStation
and you know especially you know they
have a lot of things that they could
thank for that in the 360 air like Call
of Duty Call of Duty really brought a
name out of the shadows in the 360 air
and you know they've built this brand
and it's like you know me and lore
kognito said like their software company
you know if you look at from just
spective of dashboards look at the
dashboard we currently have in the
dashboard the Xbox one first came out
with it's like it's nighttime they
absolutely and you know that's the one
thing you can like you know you can
really if they had gays with that in the
we get constant updates like
consistently I think it's you know
people remember they used to get those
monthly updates just the monthly it's
like I feel like we're here new new
stuff they do into the dashboard every
other week now absolutely absolutely but
is it enough you know without they need
solid games to go with it but you know
that's the only thing they like and
right now it's like Cal has said
multiple times in the past this has been
a 2017 issue every year before that it
wasn't an issue they launched plenty of
games mm-hmm I need to think about the
thing about Microsoft with the whole
release in the fall thing it's the it's
the it's the leader delusion young what
I'm eating yet is thank you and you had
to 360 you would drop gear to five six
seven eight million there was no major
competition besides called the duty but
the games were so different your fan
base would pick it up regardless halo
saying you know I'm saying
halo drops in the fall you don't want to
put nothing around halo back on 360 but
Master Chief outside Tom squid on them
say people yet hailing us presentation
was crazy
mmm so it's not that game anymore it's
not that right right now only game
Microsoft has to even a little bit
compete in the fall and it can't compete
in the fall sony sony has games that you
know sony don't even really have games
to compete in the fall besides The Last
of Us it's is it's a different
generation and it's also a different
mindset of gamers yeah the myosin has
changed if you look at what's being
played the most in in you look at what
is is is really dominating is really a
lot of these longevity games like the
MMO and destiny ends and the old watches
and stuff like that and I think that's
why Phil was trying to make that point
when everybody got on him about Zelda
and horizon on he told the truth
Oh use those games so um and then you
know so with that being said Microsoft
was just putting themselves in a
position where they
have to kind of wake up to reality that
the games that used to be major hitters
aren't anymore and any define something
not to replace them but to pick up where
those games had leg on Zach exactly now
that's what I think the crackdown comes
in I just really wanted acts tempo class
problem I'm actually passed a value for
that um Tim now we know that the Scorpio
is going to be very powerful and we
already know Microsoft said that they
won't have Scorpios cluesive games but
in your opinion right because you know
as as I see that you know the Microsoft
that that green runs in your blood
yeah what box mom family in here exactly
we all green in here um I know we want a
new system we love hardware we are way
junkies right but let's just say what
must they do what game do should they
put out a game that Scorpio only that
you have to get the system for that you
have to see this power with and it's not
VR because VR makes you buy a headset
and adds more dollars to the purchase
you know the game the headset and system
it's a little bit too much for certain
people don't you think they should have
a game that shows you the power of this
system and it's not held back by the old
generation um to be honest I think that
they're they're strictly gonna do the
quick console refresh meaning they're
gonna do the same exact thing that
Sony's doing with PlayStation Pro uh I
think that that what you're talking
about is maybe something that they could
do at the end of a generation maybe when
it's like far gone and people just like
Xbox one everyone's Scorpio but I
understand what you're saying but I
don't think that they're gonna do it I
do think that in a way that's always
gonna be you you're gonna always be the
only thing that you could see like you
said is is a R or VR but that requires
another person so yeah I do think it I'm
gonna stay within the console refresh
with the whole generation out the next
console that comes out then that's a
different story
I don't know how the tech will evolve at
that I don't know how Playstation or
Xbox is gonna be like to us say hey you
know we're going to either you're gonna
support all your games and they've
always said that they do this or we're
going to start fresh because when you do
start fresh it opens up even more stuff
like you're talking about to only extend
Scorpio and it would be something to see
the whole but you always have that
common denominator of Xbox or
Playstation this in this same type model
yeah I don't know how long it's going to
go to my destiny the reason why I asked
you that is because I have a PlayStation
Pro this absolutely no reason that I got
rid of my regular PlayStation what is
true is like it's in him with no real
game benefit for because I have my boy
bring over his regular PlayStation and I
put in a zero horizon going in and I put
it on the same floor k television I
swear to god I'm gonna tell you with my
own eyes I looked at it and I said mmm I
could have saved a hundred especial Pro
- I think that I think though as time
goes on
it'll be like remember wouldn't be in
this generation it was like the they had
these cross-platform games where like
you know they have the 360 version and
then they have the Xbox one
I do think down the line that they'll be
specifically targeting Pro and Scorpio
and you get like a really kind of high a
great experience on the lower end I I
think a good way that they could you
know benefit the Pro and Scorpio users
is you know mainly the Scorpio because I
don't have a pro right now but uh is is
you know instead of you know trying to
make a new game that's built around
Scorpio because I think at right now
it's like you know it's like Lord Tim
dog said I don't think they'll do that
until you know enough time goes by with
the majority they're hardcore have
upgraded because that's the people who's
going to [ __ ] it's going to be the
hardcore that's the people that's going
to go on Twitter but if you know a lot
of them have you're going to get a bunch
of Lord Kings it's like oh well you
your upgrade I feel like if they you
know they want to stay away from that
that area for a while like make
different you know make enhancements
something existing games like like they
did with battlefield 4 from the 360 the
Xbox one where you went from 12 to 24 on
the right if you do some little stuff
like that it doesn't make a significant
like you know it's like I I write in a
rant like I get everyone likes 4k but
I'd rather see gameplay mechanics
upgraded then resolution amen that's
real talk
let's go talk I want to get too far oh
we stretch this topic a bit but um what
I want to do is want to close up with it
is all the noise you guys are making
fantastic points and I think that on you
know we do realize that this is a very
significant III in the history of Xbox
in a long time
I mean in backs-to-the-wall there's a
lot of pressure here the fan the fan
page feels away you know I definitely
agree with locale Forrest you know the
money having to be spent right and
things have to be invested right we're
gonna get into that with the next topic
but I also do feel a passion from you
know more 1000 King because it's like
you know they have to show us now you
know we we've been patient we're trying
to see what this vision is long term but
it's it's show time now will it all be
neatly probably not but as long as we
have that roadmap and have that
confidence back in the brand I think
that's key and what I just want to
reiterate back to the fillers legacy we
want to put that up is because there's
no secret most of the lords know you
know I'm a big Peter Moore guy that was
my guy you know and as far as he did a
lot for the Xbox brand as as far as the
360 error now to Cal's point I'm not
gonna say that all the business
decisions were of or frugal and other
smartest but from an aggressive
standpoint to put Xbox on the map after
coming off of the OG xbox right which
was the foundation but you know it was
bleeding money so they really jumped
into that next you know next generation
phase pretty quickly so it just I don't
know Peter wanted to me represented an
aggressive Xbox and I'm not
disrespecting feeling any means he could
be looking at this thing and say okay
financially we will
you know that that wasn't you know the
smartest decision investing in DLC
didn't say it was it was in unlucky I
believe it was a the ballot of whatever
he told nothing about a Tony in the down
they spent like ten or late twenty
million dollars one that late I don't
even know how long bro don't make us
waste some of the decisions were bad and
it's from a financial standpoint from a
gamer stamp it's back then they were
very okay with opening the checkbook
alright bomber was back in the truck up
you know everything was was everything
and into their defense though he also
had to deal with the red ring of death
right and we had to do all that money
that was lost now all I'm saying it I
just like the mindset the mindset of
going for and I'm not saying Phil's not
I just feel that sometimes with the
statements he puts himself in a tough
position with the Xbox faithful you say
you like you know what I'm saying dog
comes he comes from my field with some
things like yeah I quite like you but
don't see it's true I mean I tell Phil
today I would tell Phil that himself
like sometimes like like the one comment
when scalebound was home then he was
like for the industry that was like a
comment that like what do you say to
that like sometimes you're looking at me
like what's what does that mean so I do
think that phil has a lot of pressure
sometimes and I do think that he's
trying to make it the best but I do
think that he has real real obstacles
that he has to face and that's that's
like any budget from from the higher-ups
Microsoft right and those guys aren't
really gamers that literally bleed into
my next topic illative through dogs I'm
gonna pass it right to you with that you
know this the importance of the
marketing deal right and um you know
obviously we know Sony has the majority
of these deals far cry Battlefront
destiny you know um and just seeing all
of this these deals go that way and um
shout to your boyfriend I believe you
made a good video and I'm reference on
to that and it's one of those things
that on one side you may say okay Sony's
invest
that that is the proof your Sony that's
the perfect counter to to something like
the scorpion right because you say to
yourself okay they got the power they're
the better version is going to be on
that platform but if we take all the
marketing and we aggressive with it we
may be able to fool the casual into
saying that this is a PlayStation
exclusive or you can get this experience
here so my question you know Tim dog is
now with these deals starting to form
out and it's looking like it's just
assassin creed origin of a know of war
is X is on the Xbox I'll you know do you
think this is the right approach do you
think you know where you at with that as
far as well Robert is not the right
approach mmm my opinion is that it's uh
something that he really shouldn't
um corner himself in which he's already
cornered himself because he's saying
that he's we're not gonna go for
marketing he's being honest he answered
that question
to that person so they're not going to I
think personally that they should try to
have marketing deals and they should try
to push their platform uwp and maybe get
the games made for that or specifically
made with extras 4k textures to push
Scorpio but they're not doing that and
that's where we're you know I mentioned
it before where we're going to talk
about this listen when the school when I
listen I've heard I've heard Phil say
that he's a competitive person okay
you're not competitive when you're
losing deals like FIFA and you're losing
what you have you have all these
cross-cutting moves you're not picking
up games like lawbreakers which is right
up your alley which you you're talking
about single players and how it's not
doing well here's a model where you
could on your platform make a lot of
money on it um you're not doing them you
have a series of course cutting moves
and it doesn't look good it's not good
to be non-competitive in a competitive
market because you competitive mmm
that's what's going on is next they're
saying they're saying hey we're taking
it we're going to
- and they're smart you know why because
their whole company thrives off of they
denis playstation to be successful
so in my opinion on the whole thing
though is that they have to do a little
reevaluation and we have to be loud as
fans we have to tell them that we're not
going to stand for it
we're not going we're not you got to be
destiny fans we're gonna give it to it
what I suspect is gonna happen and this
is like really gone line is that we're
gonna have probably an e3 where
questions are still abound and then
score was gonna hit I do things to do
good and I do think that you're gonna
change the mindset of of things if phil
has to relook at things that maybe he
said and he has to reevaluate it's the
thing that changes you know if he gets a
big third-party deal in 2018 you know
people are gonna say well you said this
sometimes you have to change with the
market and you know it you know
sometimes it's great that Phil talks to
us and and he's open like this but it
does have some things where people put
you in draw lines in the sand now but
this angle is absolutely he has to just
be open you could re-evaluate things and
I just say be aggressive be competitive
you know I'm sorry but when I see a lot
of Xbox executives and people in there
thing and they're promoting horizon and
they're saying this is dope this and
that it doesn't feel right it's like
like you're lose it's like the Giants
going on the Cowboys thing it's a good
analogy it is like sports team is true
it's absolutely true I don't know so I
do think that this is a learning process
and Phil always talks about that that's
what I like about Phil is he's open to
to think about things and he's open to
maybe changing his mind so that's my
feeling on the whole thing you know I'm
all talk we're gonna all go into it but
that's just you know I don't I don't
think I'm losing my mind but I would be
honest defeat the deal that's true
that's disturbing to me like it's like
wow like I think out of all of the more
I think of all the marketing does
they've ever lost that's the one that's
gonna hurt them the most yet if I
thought one kind of
the wrong way but I don't want to get to
a locale we gotta get it Ben we got to
get a bid on this one it's just a secret
I mean I was gonna bring up the FIFA
deal and um that definitely is an L on
their part that's the great thing about
the great thing about Microsoft and what
they did Europe wise was the FIFA in the
Forza - the two games that really
dominate in the Euro market is racing in
football you know you're a fool so for
them losing FIFA that's that's in me
that's huge but what it tells me they
stay more like a lucky man because they
got the NFL did that they were lost that
that would have been absolutely
embarrassing because I'm like who you're
the you're the you're the market leader
for NFL like the real NFL they got
surface laptops and all that stuff
Microsoft's commercials then you turn
around and you lose madden doubt that
just be crazy but they lost fifa so what
it tells me is that microsoft truly is
actually investing your first party I
say only thing I could see that money
going to besides the besides them
building the platform with all these
features it's like you have a
feature-rich console you have to put
games on it don't use those features
mixer is a great great feature to have
when it comes to streaming they want to
make sea of thieves like destiny this is
the one thing that they even a rare guys
when I talk to some of the rare guys
this is the one they always talk about
how this game would be like when you
stream it this is a mindset this is the
mindset that Microsoft has they're
trying to go on this grand scale to try
to hit as many people and even get into
the entertainment business of video
games you look at what they're doing
with their tournaments with the ki
tournament and automate gears tournament
they're they're trying to move beyond
just games and move into bigger aspects
this is what Microsoft does they get
their hands and one thing I do they
branch out and try to reach as many
other things and this one job as much as
possible but in order to keep that base
in order to keep fans happy in order to
keep fans lawyer you're gonna have to
produce more first party titles they did
an excellent job
early on they fell off now and I think
with Scorpio it allows them
to kind of restart it's not going to be
a console that everybody's going to buy
I just if people think it's gonna
outsell Xbox one it's not what but they
have an opportunity to get fresh bread
and fresh blood in and show up some new
games that run on Scorpio will
eventually be downgraded to Xbox one and
those will be new IPs for both the Xbox
and Xbox Corp yeah let's just hope they
don't hire new talent put them in VR
stuff like they did they do I mean Casey
Hudson oh I've had nothing like the
writer of Qatar in Mass Effect and Mass
Effect is worrisome malevolent probably
some of the best story written stories
out there just long lost the only
Western RPG you've had as you don't have
this man writing your next RPG right
like there's enough I just hope never
know but that's to have something you
know the Houmas that Bethesda has
something for Microsoft but it was time
dogs exclusive if they do I pray to God
it is disdained at be an anchor talk
about all the time this was a star point
star field some yeah in having something
but there's the exclusive I think that's
the first time it's ever happened in the
gaming industry yeah that would be huge
Oh Lord looking you want to jump in yeah
I think you know me like we don't expect
some pot lovin um okay I don't think we
sit there and know Phil's pie also I
know marketing deals come from when
you're the market leader
mm okay so anytime we were the market
leader we controlled that market because
we had people believing that you only
played it here it was only here so you
you if you don't have the console sales
and you're making money from that to go
to the board to tell the board
yo we did this we have this money we
made this money here now we need these
marketing deals to secure this to make
more money here because when the public
believes that we control the gaming
industry we will sell more systems they
don't PlayStation doesn't sell systems
the fact that zero rising dawn zero
rising dawn if they have 60 70 million
Playstations out there it didn't sell 60
70 million Playstations I mean I'm a
units it's so probably one or two I
think one of the main reasons that
they're incorporating you know hardcore
Windows 10 is because that's thought
they can take to third parties to get
more marketing it's like look like we
might just have a call to infrastructure
but we got millions of people on Pete
that's using Windows 10 that's all
potential sells right and they have to
work from a position from behind and I
know you know you say you will feel a be
aggressive but when um this guy took
over from the regular Xbox he was in the
position of winning when they they
launched it 360 he was already ahead of
the PlayStation 3 he was in a position
they were leaving hey they were right
the place you didn't come out at that
point and they came off of a failed
system though let's be honest like the
xbox OG xbox Duke controller you know as
much as I love that system and it had a
hard drive in an Ethernet the controller
I felt like I needed three her arms yeah
the one you can kill a small trade a
small controller guys pretty pretty sure
some some monks and stuff we're
considering using those controllers as
nunchucks and not actually that is that
when even though we still have to give
my boy Peter some credit like from the
stand point yes he had he had the
backing from these guys but they did
come from a stand point that it was the
Xbox one was a failed system as much as
it had innovation you know they came up
with a plan and they launched it a year
ahead into the market and they gained
some share that's all I'm saying I know
what you're going with would fill in the
comparison though yeah but so you know
Phil is playing from behind the
eight-ball you know he got bet you're
out the bed and you know right that's a
lot of things that people don't talk
about is this is the hand he was dealt
exactly and the climate it was
especially after the reveal the Xbox one
was an absolute disaster mopr standpoint
yeah we were we're in transition and
Playstations in position you know you
know what I'm saying
you're right now you're right pocket
leader always always is gonna snatch up
those deals exactly that's that's what
the way the market it feeds is usually
the flashes out to so I do maybe that's
it but it's just honestly it just feels
like when Microsoft at least when you
lose big ones that you have it just kind
of feel all breakers what breakfast is
is it was a big deal I mean that but the
FIFA one was it was a combination of uh
it's what my penny man law breakers
couldn't wait anywhere I don't care but
that don't know but it's just not a fit
if it is is that is the punch to the gut
no doubt but the law breaker just feels
it's almost like a backhand it's like
because obviously the history would
click click shot you're not looking and
the gold digger mentality developers are
gold diggers yes roll [ __ ] mentality so
they're looking at who's spending them
chips who's in it club spilling it out
and Sony's in that Club baby they
selling out every night goodbye pay the
bill or in the back snack of chips and I
just a chip oh you could argue that they
were smart for doing that because now
the game is talked about more than ever
if it can yeah rocks poverty it wouldn't
be such a big deal now it's a big deal
Oh point yeah that's a good point that's
a good point
look I want to get lost on quiet most of
where you're at with this the marketing
deal this whole deal
I think these third-party deals are
absolutely unnecessary evil and and
Microsoft absolutely to be more
aggressive in pursuing them because uh
going back to something that Lord Cal
said earlier is something that I've kind
of echoed in the past perception becomes
reality very quickly very very hmm you
absolutely at the moment you're sitting
in if you look back from the start of
this year you look at marketing deals
with Resident Evil you look at all the
first party stuff that can a second
party stuff they came exclusive to Sony
then you look at lawbreakers you look at
now far cry
five you look at destiny like the
perception when when you're talking to
the regular swimmer right when you're
talking to the regular consumer the
regular consumer is going to watch um
the commercials on their TV and say I'm
getting a Playstation because all of
these things are coming to PlayStation
even and again the genius marketing is
genius marketing and if you look at we
haven't mentioned this before but if you
even look how they're marketing the ps4
Pro now you have commercial dammit CAD
dynamic mold on the checkerboard exact
according to checkerboarding but to the
person who's not us who doesn't know
that they're like well - all has true 4k
gaming but this is dynamic dynamic 4k
they might react on a massive better
than regular Scorpio 4k - let's let's
put ourselves in the mindset of the
casual consumer they don't know what we
know they don't know this house of law
sava I'm feeling you continue I said as
the casual consumer is what there's
marca needles and gaming what it's like
I just thought everyone came out for
everyday I don't know there's marketing
dude Goodell is up again with with the
room back to the perception thing Phil
needs to counter moves by Sony with
direct counter moves in that same realm
you can't say okay I'm gonna counter
this marketing deal by doing something
different that offers something
different to gamers and they may be in
the long term gives them something
that's even better but they're not gonna
see it that way so in terms of
aggressiveness and perceived
aggressiveness you absolutely have to do
your best to try to counter with exactly
what they're hitting you with it's just
it's a pretty again maybe it's not the
smartest thing to do and it can going
back to making Xbox of the best play
place to play in terms of platform and
the long term I can see the long game
but in in the short term it's not
working because again we're going into
e3 now and Sony hasn't specifically done
anything and people are really excited
about what's coming out of so
and all of a sudden people people who
aren't us people who aren't us going
into the Microsoft stuff they kind of
like look doesn't have much they
absolutely need to show stuff they don't
have much of anything it's like it's
like the tone is down boo boo are kind
of on the line or not necessarily in the
know an accent again a perception thing
what Microsoft has to do to combat that
just I just want to say some real quick
go hard
Microsoft has an opportunity to combat
all of these marketing deals if they're
able to get every single one of those
games in 4k on YouTube social media will
be the way to combat the marketing where
it's funny I think about you know being
a New Yorker and how back in a day if
you're a Knicks fan if you're a Knicks
fan I feel sorry for you because I'm a
freak bad right now my damn self
but of the Ragman game if you're a
Knicks fan there was no better place to
go between LA the Knicks you know Boston
Chicago something like that because yeah
it was the media capital of the world
but in today's world you got social
media so it's not as big anymore you can
go to an Oklahoma City of Milwaukee
Bucks and still be able to be a
superstar now because you got YouTube
you got Facebook you got Twitter you can
get your stuff out there to the public
so with mixer and being able to do 4k 61
square meals you're able to huge over
those games and get all of those fans
streaming showing these games off doing
comparisons putting it out to the public
the casuals the moms and dads won't see
it but the kids will and when we can't
see it and if the kids to understand it
then they have an opportunity to combat
it but initially initially before those
games released yes Sony has an unlock
and it's definitely let me jump in on
that to low-cal because I wanted to
bring in his whole I know last I hope
you guys weren't around so that but we
talked about the whole significance
obviously we know destiny to destinies
you know our foundation from this
podcast but we talked about the
significance of the destined to Fiasco
and the concern of because Sony has the
marketing deals we again like that now
granted the destiny Activision Sony
love triangle could be a unique thing in
the history
of gaming but what the precedents I'm
worried about is that if a game is
marketed by Sony and they have those
deals does this offset the power of the
scorpio does this now put the developer
in a position where they may have to use
the Sony as the lead platform and force
parity out again I'm not saying that
that couldn't definitely can happen but
I'm concerned that they may use this and
from if it's if it's something that Sony
can do it's the perfect counter right
you know all I'm saying is that it would
be a shame because to me coming into
this whole III I'm like okay Tony's got
the marketing fine you know but if Xbox
just shows ok our game runs better you
know in Destiny's case you know we can
do for k60 without issue
right if they are able to do that then
to me that offsets it you know because
now it's like this is definitely the
premier place to play it regardless to
whether you have a little map or a gun
you're mean you're not 4k 60 so to speak
so I'm just concerned with that this
marketing that's in place
will this stifle the scorpio as far as
being able to to actually showcase that
the game is superior from a technical
standpoint what do you think
like look at letting go um a marketing
deal is a marketing deal you know you're
you're going to get it you're going to
advertise it you're going to show the
game off they can't control what the
developer does Microsoft couldn't truck
couldn't control again that they had
marketing for that came on at nine
hundred people ran at 1080 on ps4 you
know I'm saying so my thing is is that I
think in and then same thing I had a
Adam boys once again we had an interview
with Adam boys mister the PS Playstation
himself at the time and one of the
questions I asked them was about you
know getting you know do developers not
favor but do developers shoes who they
want to do they get games for a
particular platform and one of the days
he basically said was no like they're
going to get the hardware
and they're going to make their game the
best that they can on that hardware so I
think if the but if the Bungie team can
make Scorpio games run at 60 they'll do
it o at the end of the day what sony has
is dlc for an entire year early right
you know I'm saying they had the
commercials they have all the stuff that
you get early which offsets that 60
frames per second and it's up to the
consumer what do you want do you want
the game that looks at runs at a better
fidelity or do you want early access to
some guns and some armor pieces like
that's that's what you have to make a
decision on and I don't think those
deals will hold people hold developers
back um because I don't think that's a
part of the contract and if it doesn't I
would hope that I would hope that gamers
will start to boycott that type of stuff
absolutely absolutely go and attend your
feedback on it real quick for you I
think is an art or or a developer you're
gonna want to make you getting the best
o'clock I don't really feel like that
parody is gonna be an issue I mean maybe
there be an odd game here and there but
overall I just I don't think that uh you
know that they're gonna be held back on
it I think they thought I count on my
mom my family count my xbox my family to
listen to I'm just so nervous as a
destiny player that's all they're just
my concern but I feel you guys that we
are going to move on to the next topic
um obviously we are some games that we
do know that it's gonna be announced on
the Microsoft stage you know games like
maybe the Kay crackdown you know see a
thieves for the whole life so when I get
this over the Lord at it you know how
legit excited about are we about the
stuff we no not at it I mean when it
comes down to it we know games are
coming up but let's be real here it's
like we know but at the same time we
don't know it's like you know we the
only thing on CDs I mean there's
obviously a kiss Sena I see these but
that we know that that's that should
come out you know a lot of people
speculate it's going to get delayed so
that's here neither here there we'll
find out at e3 hopefully
mici uh stated okay we've seen
screenshots I don't think we've seen any
solid gameplay cracked out we AC [ __ ] on
that in like two years
uh you know when it comes to stuff like
that I mean cuphead I believe cuphead is
coming out this year it is a pretty do
you guys think cuphead will come out
like Ed III because there's a lot of
speculation going on that what do you
think is supposed to supposed to they
said it was supposed to be releasing
spring 2017 or like yeah like around
this time but we haven't heard anything
from it so you know who knows at this
point but when it comes down to it like
out of all of those games and i'm hype
for all of them you know i played a lot
I play both the crackdowns countlessly
hours and hours because I love that
aspect of being a hero and I like for
some reason I know there's going to be
people with it's gonna completely
disagree with this statement but I like
I was down with collecting the agility
orbs I don't know why but it's like
every time you got one of these you it's
like you you felt yourself get more
strong and strong it it's like it before
you know what you could jump over
buildings and so you know I like that
aspect I hope that they take that it's
it would it what it all comes down to is
what is Microsoft doing with these games
are going to take the core aspect of
core foundation of these games have
build on it or they gonna try to
completely you know left fill the whole
franchise itself to reiterate it to make
it more appealing to casuals and then
end up isolating the the initial
hardcore feza that love the game just be
start out with I hope that you know that
they build off the foundation and expect
the the hardcore fans to pick it up of
those fans of those perspective you know
the you know the the franchises that I
was referring to but for some reason I
feel like crackdown like I feel like
crackdowns the most important IP that
they got this year is important he does
they I don't want them to have to fall
back on say to decay like I really don't
want that like they have Stacey day
state of the case my baby that's the one
on me that's the one I'm most excited
for some people are snoring on stated
occasion why did that because always the
first word was trash the first one was a
twenty dollar arcade game let's lay off
the first mini it has so much absolute
it had permit
F and I'm just thinking about that right
now because I'm excited I'm just
thinking about from a four-player co-op
standpoint and and just if even if put
it this way stated the case so I love
again so much that if they gave me the
same game with just four player co-op I
would still go crazy now you're talking
about 4k Scorpio enhanced you know with
some time behind it bigger map and
hopefully some more things to do like I
think that to me that game represents
kind of like the true Walking Dead
experience with communities and food and
sources and like I love that game like I
think that's it that's a hit on the low
and people are really snoring on it I
wonder so that that's my would you guys
I noticed in the comments section would
you guys notice board Tootie said uh you
know he throws that days gone has more
height would you guys agree with that I
do think that days gone has more - same
ip it's a new IP and you know like the
first one was good was beloved but a lot
of people keep forgetting that that was
a double a that was that wasn't even a
double a title that was like I did it in
your garage type that so people forget
about but you know like it's been very
known that Microsoft is I don't even
think Microsoft funded the first one I
think they helped port it I mean I'm not
sure I would know I mean they're
actually funding money through this
title this time my mic which is all fun
that the first one first one
oh the first one but uh I checked on a
second one but you know they tenure I
think they do have a 10-year contract
like Al said but you know it's like I
said like out of all those games you
know we obviously don't know anything
new we don't know you know anything is
that they're going to announce at e3 but
like I think the most important thing is
a crackdown got to be less crackdown got
to be everything they they said they
can't go out there be like yeah we
scrapped the original game this is what
we have now and - they got to show these
games in a in a good light like you know
I'm not obviously I'm not mean like you
know legit light they gotta show these
gay
that's really solid gameplay of these
games that really show you what like
stay to decay expect you know 4 player
coop coop if you know gameplay teaser
and cracked out people like I want to
see the single-player no they got to
show the destructive engine of crackdown
because that is what they're boasting
and they got to show the multiplayer
crackdown and it's got it's got to go
out without a flaw no you know a charter
floor where the the gameplay just go
completely goes out remember that when
that happened when they show Charter for
the gay play like legitly just kind of
come down they had to reset the whole
gameplay like they can't have no hiccups
it's got to go without weight without
eating any messed up
Lord Lord tip dog what did you do you
are generally excited about out of the
stuff that we know um crackdown 3 is
much is what really I care about me
state of decay I think is gonna be good
but crackdown 3 I really hope that they
blow the doors off for me nice I think
we're talking about it and you were
saying that that could be the game that
kind of gets people on the platform like
holy [ __ ] they uh you know the
impressions when they showed it to the
press believe in 2015 was like unseen
like everyone was like this isn't seeing
this is so impressive you can do a
google search and you I think Guardian
saw a couple people saw it so that's the
one that I'm really looking forward to I
hope they have two announcements but I'm
totally befuddled if they do what it
could be I do think that um I want to
see what also comes out we don't know
this but what comes out of Japan the
Japanese isn't exactly I'll get into
that you gotta get into it mm-hmm good
data lot less off what are you excited
about I'm kind of legit excited about
everything to be honest I mean what for
the I mean for the seven is gonna be the
showpiece for what Scorpio can do like
just destroying you know framerate and
stuff like that it's gonna be a
beautiful game I'm not a I'm a big for
the horizon guy I'm all of the hassle
research so there's a the technical
aspects of seven don't appeal to me as
much but I will purchase it
sickness is me up
do that um then in terms of a cup header
below definitely with either one of
those coming out would be would would
make me happy um and then when we talk
about state of decay state of decay to
has the ability with the with the
addition of the four-player multiplayer
the fact that they have more time and
money to hopefully create a vaster world
a denser world where we're you know area
to area there's a lot more to do um more
depth in terms of how you handle your
communities and in terms of the
individual relationships you have with
the members of the community um I love
the first one and I think they can
really blow the doors off with the
second one so hopefully that's what
they're doing uh same for crack down
crack down I love the first crack down
it was one of those titles on the
original Xbox 360 that really kind of it
just showed but we've wanted from what
we want from Microsoft now um and I
think doubling down on the concepts of
the original forget about double down on
the concepts of the original um and blow
that out with with the destructible
world and again making the world denser
and and have more stuff to do I think
something that Cal mentioned about
making and the scenario that Cal
mentioned about making like strong story
moments within this this huge world and
adding the destructibility I think I
think that can be their killer game at
the end of the year and and hopefully
I'm not sure you know how sure we are
about this coming out this year but see
if thieves
I think see if he has the ability I
think he'll mention this also see if
these have the ability to be the pirate
destiny if they do it right if they they
make this if they make the world
interesting to be in they give you
missions with your friends that are
interesting and and deep um and if the
combat can hold up I think they have a
winner on their hands it's just and it
doesn't even matter in terms of see if
thieves if there's this over like in
destiny there's an overarching sort of
and storyline that kind of put gels
everything together I don't necessarily
think you need that and see if thieves
cuz I think it takes itself
more lightly but if the moment-to-moment
gameplay and the and the individual
little missions you go on with your band
uh with your band of pirates are is fun
I think I think you can definitely mmm
all it's something like like a pirate
destiny and I think it'll be a big Lord
Lord King
what are you in general excited about
about the yo stuff we know well okay um
everybody you know said all the great
stuff um I think that cuphead is going
to drop the same day while he's on the
show I think that's gonna be his mic
drop moment as they drop sake ops okay
um the game that I'm really excited
about beside Co thieves really it's two
of them state of decay and see if these
uh the reason why those games will
extend the longevity of the system and
once you get into those MMO type of
feelings of the game state of decay is
with the four player with the friends
joining in and feeling like walking dead
Oh beautiful I love that that that will
be fantastic all four of us just get
there and you know we ride in the cars
and we're searching houses and you know
we're building our forts and stuff yeah
okay grab Michelle let's go that's three
CDs that MMO fill our own IP original
finally you put in the rear guys the
work you mean a game you can blame me
for everything that goes wrong if you
did it then I'm gonna blame you um
continue but to just just to say we're
drinking in the bottom of the ship
hilarious ah we got the booty we what we
feel this is it can't we gotta alphas
and the beta's and that you know it's
been a little different experience for
some but hopefully they can refine about
I do agree with you but like the
potential is so much so much did yeah
real quick if we got one more and then I
want to move on to a to cow and then we
move on after that if you got if you had
one more game at you you're excited
about besides the uh see if these
get on it no no I'm good that was it it
was uh no cos theta decay and see a
thieves really see it these cool no
doubt Lord cow look at you uh legit
excited about uh crackdown for one mmm
not I'm not a Forza guy like I try to
play motorsport I can't do it horizon
I'll play um but honestly I'm I'm
looking for something new and the reason
why I'm saying that is because for two
years practically we've seen these games
at this point like we've known for two
years these games are coming I need to
be wowed by something and you know it
doesn't have to be Japanese don't want
you being a court or that's all you want
I do
who wouldn't want it but I'm just saying
that I think Microsoft definitely needs
to surprise us with something new
something impressive as something
triple-a you know they would the one
thing they haven't done this generation
the last two generations was dropping
game on the level that was the
definitive game for that gen Halo was
the definitive cash box here's the
definitive game for 360 and we don't
have one for Xbox one yet valid point
anchored valid show on a fusion frenzy
announced oh I'm not that's a tough day
but but but they definitely need
something that's going wow now um I mean
I don't know we'll get into this later
or not but you know I got we are I get
the press releases the stuff like that
as a media outlet and you know I got the
Sega press release boom across what we
go through it we go go to Kelly's mr.
Bob Ocean and with it and with the press
release they talked about the CEO
stepping down but in the process of them
talking about they talked about some
deals and partnerships that they had
after him stepping down anything that
caught my eye that you take podcast was
how they talked about how they got
Microsoft and a lot of people are
looking back like oh whoa
Sega owns Creative Assembly but what
they did was it used to be
Crytek after you lose cause quite
exciting right
yeah yeah got a tech black C is now
Creative Assembly Sofia which is that
entirely different new studio so even if
even if it was halo wars to the fact
that they bring up releasing rebooted
new IPs and older IPs
then I'm excited about what's a good may
have with Microsoft and then you know
now I'm not trying to throw a then got
the about scale down they did redo the
trademark but I'm not saying that maybe
going to Sega's not a wise decision
Panzer Dragoon was on weirdo oh my god
they work with you know a lot of RPGs
and you're gonna hang up to somebody its
Sega is trying to revive a career
they're doing a big focus on triple A's
and not just pumping out all these small
games
hey handing off scalp out to them or
maybe working on something new with sag
will be big they are going to Tokyo Game
Show this year and maybe we'll see
something from Microsoft or Sega again
yeah that would be great we definitely
definitely touching that later as well
but yeah you could Java some bombs I'm
so excited about that definitely excited
about that I'm gonna move on real quick
um this one would try to fly through I'm
gonna leave this one on so pretty much
obviously Lord addict and I my brethren
we put ourselves out there on the
chopping block we made a couple months
all I know it is it made us we made a
very bold prediction based on tea leaves
and theories about the Scorpio price and
this arm actually I'm also about the
release date and we we put a gun to our
heads and we said you know what we think
it would being smart on a Microsoft
spark they can release this thing in
August he said the bold month of August
and my part in the Lord addict he said
you know what and I said like you crazy
man they can't do August you gotta
follow traditional you know set console
releases which is always a November
thing and you know most Microsoft
consoles drop around my birthday was
around like the 15th so but he said we
said lock Cognito man you forgettin the
s dropped in August I'm like oh he did
it I forgot about that we just started
talking why would mourn we started
looking at cuttings with the nests they
did like a why
all sauce oughta soft-launched like oh
sorry you know they they strategically
put the expensive one out there in
August it was like they knew their hard
core base would buy it in August and
then they're like and for the rest the
casuals can have that [ __ ] in September
knocked over exactly so I want to bring
it to the roundtable now obviously Lord
addict and I we got our heads on the
chopping block we still going down with
the ship but at the end of the day
obviously we do know that it's
potentially we can be wrong what I
wanted to bring to the round table real
quickly will file this off is one what
do we think the price is gonna be
released I know Cal you've got a gun to
your head on that with Lord ahead I bet
you guys got some good ore and then also
you know the release date buddy when do
you think it's gonna drop and also
though another caveat on it if it drops
traditional console style November right
would this be disastrous for Microsoft
and I want to skate Lord Tim dog onyx I
haven't heard much from him I've been
you know as far as his opinions on this
as far as price released a stripper deny
what Tim goes well yeah I think it's
gonna be 399 $4.99 excuse me that's what
I'm saying I think I point to that
because of the one terabyte hard drive I
think if it was $4.99 it would be to
just just cuz it's like seems like it's
that price point it really seems like a
low terabyte to me plus I think that a
lot of the stuff that we seen money-wise
is that maybe they're they'll actually
break even or even take a little bit of
a loss net and one of the ways you could
do that is do cost-cutting move so
obviously it's a business so I'm gonna
say 399 499 whoa she released artists
release date now I'm hearing I heard
things like in August and the Lord
I had a schedule I think I think the
reality is it's going to probably be
October late October 24th October 24th
that's where they would might want to
sit it but don't be surprised if it gets
to know
remember middle of November and I don't
think that's gonna hurt the system you
don't think it would hurt it if it did
John um you know I think it's good I
just I just have a feel it's gonna be a
hot ticket item so it doesn't matter I
obviously want to get earlier but I
think whenever it comes out it's gonna
win that month in MPD that's just my
prediction from way back one but I do
think it's gonna be a hot ticket item at
399 I think that that's where they give
them some you know leeway now if it's
$4.99 then like me earlier release okay
so you think the price that really has a
factor in to kinda buy yeah I do but I
think that 399 and November October
areas what the whole plans always been
and I think they're pretty much sticking
to it I like I I just think the 399 even
though a lot of people and their right
to question that because of everything I
just feel like the way the way things
are going that they can get away with
doing I might drop with that and then
you know and then have these other
cost-cutting moves and kind of be
understandable and it would be it would
be a direct blow I mean not blow but it
would be a direct competitor to the pro
at that price yeah well I did the pro
drop it definitely but obviously I don't
think they would harm the drop maybe the
holidays but I think eventually they
will be the same price but I do want to
ask one question real quick for me on to
the next guest uh I I'm curious what the
people in the chat had to say put put
the price and date in the chat yeah yeah
put that in it while we wait for the
photos os's loss saw haven't gotten your
feeling on release date i don't believe
i think i remember hearing you talk
price one time we never actually it's
okay number doors i can't remember you
so refresh me alright so i mean my
thinking again i would love it to come
out in august but i just think they play
the north they play the long game and
they kind of stick to the cadence
they've always had and I'm looking at
late October early November I think
maybe it's a little earlier than gentle
then it usually is so maybe earlier
November but I still think they stick to
that sort of
cadance um in terms in terms of price I
think I sort of agree with with Tim dog
in that they can definitely get away
with releasing two SKUs because that way
that way you're speaking you're speaking
to the you're trying to speak to the
casual gamer you chat you trying to
speak to the regular consumer and you're
also speaking to the hardcore because I
think if you release this system at $500
then the conversation you're having is
with us you're having the conversation
not talking you're not trying to talk to
the person just walking into a game stop
because I'm price alone you're probably
going to get shot down on whether that's
fair or not um considering you know how
powerful the system is going to be so I
think definitely the only issue I see
with that is that when you talk about on
a 399 system it's very easy for most
people I would say to look at that
disparity and say well I'll get to 399
once because a it's very easy to UM to
just buy external storage for your Xbox
one you buy oh you can buy 4 terabyte
external hard drive and and you don't
have to worry about having 2 terabyte
internal drive so in terms of the bells
and whistles that may be a $4.99 system
can have I could definitely see having a
be 2 terabyte SSD or hybrid SSD uh
redesign the lead controller with some
additional bells oh don't say that
maybe some sort of packing game may be
some sort of packing game to
differentiate um because if they do
release it at 2 skews then you look
you're seeing looking at most people by
a benign skew mom but that yes that's
kind of what I'm looking at man I just
and I certainly hope it's August
I certainly benefits while I get him
just so you think that they could
release like kind of not a bare-bones
but a minimum scorp you know and then uh
um even more advanced Scorpio be with
the exercises in and a controller
correct yes I don't think that a dis
list one is a really good you know
availability because a lot of the year
ago they could they could
cut the price more like what did I drop
to Scorpio for wait but wait wait we
want one question will act oh but a
discus will I mean we gotta assume that
this thing is gonna mimic it as far as
the 4k blu-ray later yeah why gateway
diggin is my personal opinion they
shoulda did that that should I'm not
saying - like that's the standard I'm
saying that that's just another option
like give an option okay so like if you
drop like you know we think it's 13 if
you dropped a 300 to 350 Scorpio without
a district it's hard to really compete
with that
mmm I understand that I just think I
just think you at that point it's a lot
of mixed messaging and you don't want to
do that I mean they've been criticized
for a long time about fleshlight used I
use my destroy since I got my L I'm not
using mice at all right now
but I think I got it yeah we know we
know visiting sales are up I will say
this I you still I love 4k movies i
watch streaming 4k if you're a video
file you're gonna want that disc to
understand way better the bitrate on a
4k blu-ray is considerably higher than
anything streaming and I have a pretty
fast dreaming so I'm at a pretty fast
internet service so it's still the
disparity start over files yeah so ah
you know I think it's important and in
terms of the messaging they've had with
Erin Breen Greenberg making sure that he
touted that um when when the S came out
I think it's not a good look to be like
nah you don't really need it go for a
cap all right so here's the problem
where you guys all get here we go shall
verdict of it here's the problem okay
look at this down problem that you have
is that Microsoft is still selling three
SKUs of the Xbox one s yeah 500 gig a
one terabyte in a two terabyte which the
tutor by is actually 399 right so if you
drop that to 300 right then you have the
one terabyte at 250 that means the 500
from now one will be 200 bucks it'll be
as though it way well I don't over be
phased out because that's the minecraft
bundle and the minecraft bundle does
extremely well so 500 you would have
that at 199 now what that doesn't do is
scream premium device after all the talk
about premium device for the x4 the
Scorpio dad's coming out at 399 when
Microsoft announced the price for the
Xbox one s we were all dere last year's
e3 you heard the crowd roar for $2.99
no one batted an eye when it was 399 mhm
no one in the crowd was like Oh 2
terabytes we I'm getting a 2 terabyte no
one hesitated right and yet all the
lingo from Microsoft has always been
about this console is not for everyone
this console is a premium device this
console is just this is for the
enthusiast that the mentality has almost
has been not to cut your locale but the
rhetoric has almost mimicked the elite
controller rhetoric it is a controller I
will say gimmick they watch a percent
and they sold only controller did and
which is why they went in a direction
with Scorpio because they understand the
supreme look at all what microcells been
doing lately is looking at premium
products and trying to match the premium
products they've been doing it with this
surface booklet max you know pricing
them out of control but people are
buying the truth but people that Scorpio
is no different
Scorpio has some new technology they've
cut the cost by customizing a lot of the
chips and everything like that but at
the end of the day you're talking about
new hardware practically almost a new
generation console right fresh eye down
they go Natalie controller in it I don't
think they will do that yeah that would
just that will make the price even
higher than what it is it is costs money
to do everything they got a 4k 60 DVR
player in there to report on what I'm
saying they can see what you say they
can have a lower cake bundle with the
elite controller and bundle up Doug
Kalitta I think they'll have is they'll
have two SKUs for the Xbox 1s they'll
have a $4.99
and they might have they might have one
lower or you might have one higher I
don't think they'll go anywhere near six
I think $3.99 is too low it doesn't
scream premium now if you want to take
bite the bullet just to put it out there
- yeah absolutely that's what you would
do drop it at 399 everybody picks it up
so no one feels left behind regardless
at the 60 frames-per-second or not
certain games and everybody feels
included regardless if you have Xbox 1s
or not but I just don't think this
console comes out at 399 I just right
now based on all the data that I have
and everything I've seen and all the
people I've spoken to none of that
scream 399 to me
right it is a quarter scream - 99 look
before I pass is looking the question I
have for you okay if it's what you say
right and if it's $4.99 historically
$500 systems have not sold well now I
understand what you're saying that this
is from the enthusiast this is for the
hardcore marketed person right you want
the premium experience I said look
looking but you know the thing I'm
concerned about is that I see where
you're going with it but I am concerned
that did that may really be a death nail
because I hate anything go ahead now
look come on a time to concern with the
cells of the Scorpio you will never hear
how many Scorpios were sold from
Microsoft you will only ever hear if
you're lucky how many X boxes have been
sold from microphone it does the same
thing with the bros that's something
like that we're going to tell you
they're not going to tell you it no but
they'll say is Oh Scorpio is a success
just like they said quantum break
absolutely actually we know damn well
want break was not a success oh no we
know that and that that generally
happens with the rhetoric of the loser
let's call it what it is right your
video SVD you're not going to put out
those numbers because I didn't reflect
favorably to you all I'm saying is with
the let you jump in Cal all I'm saying
is with that price point right if they
do come out at 500 like you say and in
they're coming out with this premium
thing now combined
with I didn't get your release date
that's what I'm gonna ask you is with
this release date of what I was in
November
you know September through November like
where do you see it sitting if it's at
this $500 price point if it's that $500
price point the hora code will buy it
because that's what we do
yep right at the end of the day we're
gonna buy a regardless that's what is
that's what it's for is for us for the
enthusiasts the people who don't get to
pick up the console right the people
who's not gonna pick it up as they can't
afford it they think it's too much we'll
pick up an Xbox 1s is still get some
1080p or 900p quality games maybe we'll
pick a essa know it what the history is
because the games for Scorpio will show
up the money that Phil Spitzer has to
put games on Scorpio will also be on the
original Xbox
so you haven't sent us their company
Xbox 1s because you'll be able to play
the new games as well just don't know
better air from better horse what in
every day or 9 at 399 you no longer are
talking about a casual box I mean at
premium console you're talking about a
console that you want to appeal to
everybody I don't think they're ready
for that two years down the road short
because then you're working on your next
console and the SKU could drop in the
price of the lower as you bring out your
next one okay button issues I see where
you don't see it being oh the only
difference I have is that if you tell
the casual Xbox 1s person that has that
that there is a better version of your
game or there is better features in said
game that they're going to want that
product okay there's the hard core than
purchase it that's the point okay but
here's but if you're a cash getting
Russian app again nothing casual Xbox
one game right the casual Xbox one gamer
has been beaten down to say that the
PlayStation is a superior place to play
now there is a new SKU which is
disappearing place to play that's all
I'm saying
you don't think that factors into the
mindset no okay no I'm just curious what
you guys think about it look can't get I
know you wanna jump in Ian's change all
the time
yeah I think Laura Cognito is suffering
from a little bit Alzheimer's because
the the rhetoric was between you and I
not you and um a lot at it uh about
August um no no we actually made a video
though
oh yeah well that equate a video remove
them slightly yeah you had all these
argued him talked about this after our
video no actually we had discussed it on
the podcast but anyway I digress um like
I was saying I see filled to the dry run
the the Xbox one s was a dry run to
predict exactly how the sales would go
with the Scorpio um remember when we
said the show and he said the price for
the Scorpio and when it was going to be
releasing it was number released in
August it was a soft release with the
higher price skew and then the lower
price you came out at a later date that
was in November right November close to
December something like that for people
that wanted that system um now I think
that he's gonna go and he's gonna follow
his same game plan he because he can
present this same game plan to the board
or to his constituents you'll check it
out
and work this way price point was this I
think the price point is going to be
$4.99 that screams premium that screams
elitist that that screams I'm walking in
the store I'm putting down my credit
card I'm putting out my cash and I'm
saying he had five hundred dollars and
let me get two of those games so um it
gives you a feeling of superiority I
think he wants that feeling when you
purchase um it might be a four-night a
449 SKU and that's the one with the
smaller hard drive that releases on a
full rollout but initially I know they
want to take the narrative going into
the season now you want that system out
before destiny drops in September so you
can show your system running better the
games running better on set system the
Activision booth is next to Microsoft at
this news right now we also
that uh was that the the wargame the
shadow of war now we also know shadow of
war comes out August in August if this
game is the game that you're partnering
with why would you not have the system
that runs it the best out it makes no
sense the tea leaves are showing you and
he's leaving you a roadmap because he
showed you last year it's going this way
now all we're going to do is debate on
price point price point $4.99 it has to
be a premium thing is not gonna be no
leet in that box
it can't be it just can't be you know
those those controllers are made very
well enough very it's a very different
process of mass-producing that
controllers compared to the regular
controller the cheaper controller um
then also adds the price tag when you
say let me get that system and let me
get an elite please and a headset please
that goes with this and let me get the
VR that's the whole league package as
you walking out to doing you looking at
the other two do I go you pick it up at
s SQ that's you so we see you'd say this
yes it's gonna be I'm a giver somebody
that's cute look I'm gonna be like oh
you're finance they still sell those
this to me it's not how coins yeah but
um yeah I like I said um because they
want to ramp up production of course you
want you're not gonna have all the
systems available ready for launch at
that period of time so you want to ramp
up production and you want to be in full
steam so if it really does pick up and
you really have to have it in demand
you're ready to fill those orders and
don't fill in the situation like
Nintendo trying to you know old man
trying to play catch up to it right they
want to be ahead of it because that Xbox
one S was available in the stores and
the way they ramped it out if you needed
one you was able to get your hands on
one for Christmas wasn't no shortage it
was available so I believe that he had
the roadmap he showed you was a dry run
and it was a
a prequel to the actual main event and
the main event is this year listen let
me I'm sorry someone is going to jump in
yeah like what his freaking Lord Kings
point um one thing the elite doesn't
cause the same to manufacturer today as
it did two or three years ago when it
first came out too so it's gonna be
cheaper okay their profit margins gonna
be considerably higher so they can they
can mess around with maybe try to put it
in inside a box but whatever that's Nate
neither here nor there we discussed in
the past and in a past podcast about how
Phil has been known to play with words
sometimes so and when you talking when
you talk about talking premium and you
so talk premium console any console at
its launch as a premium console at a
premium price whatever that price maybe
that's what premium is at that moment
and it as the console cycle continues
well then that good you know something
else takes over and that becomes the
premium product right so to review to be
able to release it at 399 calling it a
premium product at its launch it puts it
in a position where it says look what I
was able to give you a 399 look at what
the pro gave you at 399 oh that's a cool
video and that's something that speaks
to the general consumer which is why I
think it's something again when you're
talking about Phil trying to make Xbox
the best place to play and to bring
people in that's something that brings
people in now another thing though
another thing that needs to be addressed
is that Nintendo is the real player
hollar
this is not a two horse race anymore
when you look at the holiday tree that's
what I'm saying
when you look at the holiday season and
you and you think about PlayStation Sony
and Nintendo the television in their own
Nintendo is the one who's good sells
well Microsoft is not paid this is I'm
so glad you said that song because I
feel like I know I've been switched
ganging and my chest has been out there
but people are not understanding that
this is a movement happening right now
underneath Microsoft's eyes and if girls
I understand premium console I get it
and I understand everything that's in
that box is probably so much from a
price standpoint you know I understand
it it may be hard to cut corners and
take an L on that whether they gotta be
very careful they've got very good on
cuz it's not that 500 you have a switch
out there
it's dangerous
it's thinking they can tell you this
right now if Nintendo has the stock to
sell they're going to blow everyone out
of the water in the holidays if they had
to stop right now they'd be blowing
everyone else up with water and no
problem but once again turns to switch
into a wii u ps4 club and Scorpio is
already ahead of the game how was they
already talked about not putting destiny
on switching president Ritchie average
doesn't matter but it does matter it
does not no it's not if it didn't matter
the we in the Wii U would have sold
third-party games matter and if we're
not getting those third-party games
because they can't run them because it
doesn't have a banner exactly if they
can't run them you fall back to have it
a Wii U handheld now yeah you have some
great first party games but you don't
have the major games that people are
playing yes and it's a great as though
that is it's still hurts that they still
hurts that console I think uh thing
about which is that the niche that is
created for itself makes it different
enough that when you talk about somebody
who only owns the next box or only owns
a Playstation when you look at a
secondary console that's the secondary
console and also I think I think some
bets should go on lower Cour you're
gonna be saying on the last planet on
the tin bill for amok I think I mean I I
think the Tendo did I did I think
Nintendo's always been the second
console though and that's my boy what
about what about these NPD numbers what
about these third parties that are
consistently be announced monster hunter
just got announced we're getting
discouraging um EA's is act all the
third parties are now because of these
numbers now that are coming out there
willing to actively invest in the
machine and say we're bringing new ports
of games now friend on Nintendo has an
amazing job and producing a new
inhale and Papa get out there because
that's what it is okay and help right
Nigel's you're not getting destiny to
crane I get the whole that we know that
oh I hear you getting a Call of Duty I
just call it duty go end of the day when
a parent walks into a store this holiday
season near dock and their dollars on
the line and you show them you could
pick up an Xbox one for $1.99 and a game
pass with 100 games for $10 they'll buy
that this is a murderous you know it's a
good discussion I don't want to get too
into this too much but I do think that
you know when these little when these
people you know these mothers and
fathers come in what did they play when
they're going up Mario and when that
game stop dude tells and Mario is out
right now they're gonna they're gonna
they're going to connect to that game
and we're like whoa that game is
definitely you know family-friendly in
that switch is definitely portable when
you both retail shop bro the the thing
people asked for the most mainly has
been PlayStation and Xbox a--'s no one
has brought up a Wii U or the DS and
that has been a big thing but Enzo's and
that's not the switch that's nice right
it's normal to switch but the D s still
is its own brand is still doing its real
absolutely I don't know the whole thing
is when it comes to picking up these new
consoles about that I'm not putting a
Scorpio in that discussion cuz that's
not what it's for I don't want I don't
want to switch and Scorpio on the same
discussion because that's not what that
is but what I'm saying is is long term
three years down the line you're going
to have a problem and that's the truth
because as as these devs start moving up
the power the the relevancy of the of
the switch becomes less and less and
more dependent a Capri just like this
can do a mid console refresh just the
same that's oh we can do that we have to
do that but the thing is the thing is
and regardless to what type of
third-party support hate yet we have to
remember the now Nintendo's more and
more Nintendo's phasing out the 3d
yes all of that development power is
going to the switch so even if it does
become a Nintendo machine now you're
looking at a release cadence of Nintendo
games maybe every month and a half
they're not phasing out the 3ds Italy's
gonna know 2d awesome
oh yeah but that's that's the are gonna
come to the point it's gonna come to the
point where they're gonna have to with a
refresh of this week's they're gonna
have to be a good Nolan a lot of the
Treadaway that is we will get everything
we got in our price in predictions and I
do agree this is gonna be very key you
know I mean I definitely hear what
everyone's saying in reference to that
look how to make some great points nine
ten make some great points in that too
so let's move on game mixer game pass oh
okay oh okay
so you would say oh man I'm super
excited because when I turned on the
game pass and it was a hundred games
there I had most of them yeah most of
them you know cuz they were released
throughout the um you know the Gold
Series
so the my son saw it and you know he saw
the games he was like wow daddy you got
all those yeah yeah so he's playing a
little uh Samurai Shodown
oh he's losing his mind it's fantastic
alright so I'm like ten dollars
yeah baby we don't tune into this this
is what its gonna be
then you saw mixin you like oh they
changed it from being this they put it
to mixer so we could broadcast that a
little bell went over my head I said
these dudes is trying to okey doke they
trying to rope a dope me they they
pulling me total closer and I'm throwing
all these punches cuz I'm buying baby
I'm tuning in this is it and more subs
equals they're going to expand the
service and at the point in time when
the service is so expensive and they
said man if we can put this on someplace
else we make more money over there for
real so how long is it before the boy
looks over and say
this system is no longer viable
this service is bringing in megabucks
if we have 50 million people subscribe
to the service what the hell do we need
is it's a system full stop making a halt
we're shut down the plants that's the
subsidy say shut down to play let's just
get this to the without there to
everybody now as a fantastic service I'm
loving it and I'm talking about four or
five years down the line where
everything will probably be on that wave
but is this the beginning of that wave
hmm at some point get there at some
point why Great Lord Tim I know we've
been talking over you a bit what do you
feel about that as far as game passes or
service in the mixture announcement - I
think the game passes well explained you
know it's for a parent it's awesome you
just say hear it up shut up kid just
plenty ticket I love it they could've
loved it I'm wiggle cow on it - yeah you
know they'll try they'll try everything
and it's a great it's a great thing it's
a it's a family thing very smart move so
I could you know it's definitely smaller
for a guy like us all of us it doesn't
mean [ __ ] it was it was six dive it was
$5 a month or if they did it maybe like
a $60 or $70 one-time deal I might do it
just to just throw the games in my
library I think I think they need a $60
price tag for the whole year
yeah I don't like the the the 10,000
ones little steep even though it's a
good price like I said it's for
different different folks
yeah and then the mixer a holy [ __ ] they
is I mean I'm a mixer and I'm not
listenable when I'm only Xbox is so
simple to just get it going it literally
takes the three buck yeah set it up and
then the co stream which is awesome I'm
doing that I'm doing that later Lord
addict I think we're going to do it nice
Jeremy I uh down are gonna do it up it's
awesome and it's just crazy how just the
name change can just like I mean they
did a lot of stuff too but just the name
change itself it just makes people look
a second time Hey
I mean I was I definitely wasn't a fan
of the need like I love be why could
they keep it but I understand from a
global territory standpoint I guess they
couldn't keep the name or whatever but
regardless whatever the name is what
it's offering is amazing which you
lucked out
yeah but what are also or the other
thing to consider is is that you know
even everyone here the requirements to
get partner right now are pretty if you
put if you go for it and want to really
do it it's it's it's it might be
attainable it's not like crazy it's 50
concurrent for two months straight that
means every time you go on you get 50 I
think that you'd have to build that up
but that's something that that that uh
really is pretty cool so I mean if
you're an Xbox person and you haven't
really started with twitch or this and
that or even if or whoever to you to get
partnered is not a hard thing on being
at World War this this thing and that's
where it's interesting to me I'm kind of
thinking maybe if I hit these numbers I
get partner now I don't know what
happens when your partner but it just
seems it seems attainable so for me I'm
actually looking to maybe do that oh
yeah I can totally see you doing it
that's I see you hit that father ship no
problem at you with it hope yeah I had
30 yeah believes my first ever I had 30
see I think that that that's where a lot
of you know a lot of things going there
also gonna have live streaming you know
I've been live tweeting on on Twitter
and you know you gotta be careful with
what you live tweak is you don't have to
can't always film everything you don't
want to fill people obviously if they're
not doing but like if you're in a place
where you know that I find that that's
also part of media is blowing up too so
I think I think makes you just hit at
the right time the biggest thing for me
what mixer is I really I don't know if
it's possible I hope they can get 4k
streaming that'd be sick and all how do
you tame hmm
loss off where you at with the game pass
in in the mixture well let me go and
with mixture first cuz make sure I'm not
generally somebody who's does any sort
of streaming but um but single play
experience to play what the improve
means they made over what a twitches are
significant and I think I think it's
huge especially when you're going to be
touting the the power of the Scorpio and
being able to broadcast games at this
high resolution high frame rate I mean
it means a lot so um I think it's huge
and people are gonna get over the name
change that's it's pretty soon it's just
gonna be second second nature of anybody
agrees um game pass game pass I'm kind
of in the same boat with lord King
whereas with you know with game pass I
when I click when I got the subscription
I had most of everything but you know
that was in that first hundred games and
that's fine but just the fact that they
had a mixture of that compact or doodad
one thing this is a clandestine way for
them to try to charge you for that
compatibility to give you the to get
people in on back compatibility and
purchase games they maybe didn't
purchase last generation and have it
folded into a monthly subscription where
they're not paying one-one amount for a
certain game they could just have access
to it all the time so that that's
another way to push their back compat um
in terms of ah the fact that they're
able to give you some Triple A games you
had halo halo 5 there that's important
if you mix that in with with Indies and
whatnot and in terms of what it becomes
in the future I'd like to see them maybe
um kind of folded into um your Xbox Live
substitute subscription at some point
and maybe drop the price a little bit
maybe make me pay five or six seven
dollars more but my xbox live
subscription and have it in mixed in
with that
that would be cool um and if you keep it
as a separate service um go the route
that Phil was talking about we're
creating like episodic content where
you're gonna be able to let
single-player games and stuff flourish
more on it I mean I think that's
important and and the long-term what
Lord King was talking about is something
that I've mentioned also is that you
moving towards games as a service
um at some point in Microsoft you wonder
if there's there's a number cruncher
saying do we even want to keep making
consoles at
point I was certainly not not like to
see that happen but it is a real
possibility and and being and it was
something that I was looking forward to
maybe seeing Nintendo at some point but
with the successes which I don't know
how viable that is anymore
um but at some point I I know the Xbox
brand is going to it's going to be alive
and well I just don't know it's going to
be a Microsoft Xbox so at that point you
know these services can they can be made
ubiquitous and to function all across
the board on everything I think that's
something they'd look into because it's
a moneymaker mmm definitely Lord okay as
far as um game passing mixer your
thoughts um I think they're both smart
and intelligent ways of expanding
Microsoft's brand and finances and
backing as far as trying to UM make sure
that they always have a constant room of
money coming in because look for how
many generations Microsoft has been in a
situation where they produce great
content but something has held them back
whether it was the slow sales of the
original Xbox the red ring of death on
Xbox 360 those have put them in a hole
plenty of times Xbox one came out and
was actually a console that work had no
issues and a ton of games but the they
messed up the communication and the
pitch of the console which hurt in each
instance every generation so if that's
hurt themselves in some way and
financially that hurts so putting these
subs out getting a mixer to get more
people invested into streaming on there
which brings in more revenue dollars
more ad dollars and get more people
watching games on your service with the
sub that works you got EA access another
sub service I want to be surprised at
some point down the line they made a
bundle get EA access and gain immunity
in a monkey I like sports games and get
played 100 games you have over a hundred
and twenty-five games for the month
mm-hmm you understand absolutely parents
dream the parents treat for 15 bucks you
can you can't be
get it working because going through the
NHL Madden and basketball games late
it'll be insane so I think Microsoft is
putting themselves in a position so when
they do decide to come out with a triple
a title that they put 60 million dollars
in 50 million dollars in and if it
doesn't pan out they just made a hundred
and twenty-five 200 now off of these
subs and all other things that they have
and they can just brush that on our
station keep moving and if something
hits and it is successful then that just
adds on to what they're trying to build
what Microsoft has to figure out is how
to keep that in-house because what I
don't think they get is that as gamers
what they see is money yeah
what they don't see is loyalty this is
the problem this is the problem your fan
base is everything and if you continue
to put dollar signs before the loyalty
of the fans who are fanatics that's what
fans are regardless if they don't think
that way your base thinks that way you
have to say that it's so political it's
terrible it really is this is all it is
it's politics it's politics but you have
to be able to think like your business
the reason why you have Xbox fans saying
Phil why are you congratulating this so
why are you saying this or why you do
these things because the fans have they
have they're given their all to you yeah
you're sitting up there treating the for
them the enemy like best friends Yonsei
like Jim dogs Giants fan but they opted
to man that Dez Bryant play boys you
know I'm saying you can't come into game
with a giant jersey and a cowboy cattle
that's what I'm saying
Microsoft has to be able to continue to
appeal to the Xbox fan that's why I PS
fans hate greeny
cuz greeny is diehard Xbox all day
greenies going on Twitter putting up
pictures at empty plaques and showing a
whole stack of people the fans what that
they they gravitate towards that and I
think Phil has to find a balance and if
he can do that with what they do on a
[ __ ] produce games they'll be good
going forward
which ramming Lord's got all my points
I'm with you guys on that I think the
game pass idea is a fantastic idea I
think that is a parent's dream if you
are new console owner and you have the
ability for 10 bucks that have all this
stuff you know this extreme library it's
it's a it's a win win and mixer to me
I've been on board all that stuff from
the beginning I love the 4k aspect I
think that is tremendous and Dom yeah
they they outside of the name I think
everything they do it is great but I
understand why the Davis so we're gonna
move on now I'm gonna bring this to Lord
signed up and kept the bosses here real
long beyond our normal time so I'm gonna
bring it to a vote for the final topic
we have two left but probably gonna have
enough time for two so um with the two
topics we have the Microsoft the Sega
actual partnership that I know we kind
of touched on a little bit if you want
to talk about that with the IPS or do we
want to talk about the UH
Microsoft VRA our situation I'm gonna
bring it to a vote yeah Sega cool
yeah yeah I can fold that into my heart
moment so no doubt no doubt
okay I won't say get to no disrespect
working are we good on oh no listen
let's go for it
Microsoft is gonna have enough on the
show with the arv oh don't worry about
that okay cool no doubt alright so you
know I'll move away in this time dear to
me Lord Tim dog loss of I mean I think
we've talked about our histories in the
past we kind of grew up Sega kids
the we kind of transitioned into Xbox
from the drink even more Kel look how I
remember you saying this as well
I'm you don't cassia yeah we were
Dreamcast kids as well and um you know
when I saw this outline from Sega and
obviously I'm stepping down and just a
hint of the re-emergence of Sega IPs I
got excited and the fact when I saw
Microsoft's name attached to them in any
capacity I got excited so the tea leaves
got in my head and I was honest I want
to bring this to a lord Tim dog and I
saw first and I will follow the rest
around table follow up you know what do
we want Microsoft to you and you know
what are we excited about you know in
our first is some of this information
that may be leaking out don't end oh you
can jump if you want hey [ __ ]
yeah definitely
you may step that a little bit so solve
okay do we get Tim back
okay we get done ami I'm here all right
I didn't want to uh here uh I think that
uh it would be great to get Saiga on
board but for me I love saying so much I
don't care if it's gonna be multiplied
probably be multi Platt but I don't also
care if it has to be doesn't have to be
Triple A like if you have all derbies
you can have it okay and you could have
it you can have it look good like look
like you know really good graphics I
just do that and I think that would sell
like crazy I think um all their games is
so many games and they got and and and
when I said that stuff everyone went
instantly crazy um so yeah they can
write their own check with that I think
that something that Microsoft definitely
should look at but who knows um I they
consider that first party or you know if
Sony gets that exclusive that's gonna be
oh no [ __ ] gas and enough efficient
move Lord Tim dog I'm hearing that any
person be that like a mercy rule that's
like you member like you're a kid
there's like ten ten nothing lay down
we're going to lay down state honestly
if that's so that's a mercy rule
like seriously um no but a golden axe I
mean seriously that is just playing my
shinobi would be like my father but you
know ultra beast I could see the most
sexy sick [ __ ] you know like
creatures and just like you know all
that the way it was and if and it could
be it could be just the same type of
walk screen to like the way it was 2d or
whatever just have it like really
updated and that's what I want I see it
being multi platinum I see them doing
real well both on yeah when you guys
know Sega is very near and dear to my
heart I get from the Master System on I
was a Sega kid long before I was a
Nintendo kid so to hear that you know
they're doubling down on bringing down I
bringing out IP that had this kind of
been dormant for a long time it brings a
smile on my face I mean the fact
just recently you know you finally
released bayonetta and vanquish our for
the PC and that makes it I immediately
it makes it something that's easily
portable to the Scorpio or and Xbox or
Playstation you know that for that
matter so that's that's cool to have
those updated versions of those great
games coming in terms of stuff that I
would love and like I said I'm gonna
fold this into my mic drop moment since
you know the combo is it when you talk
about Sega IP that can really flourish
at this moment in gaming obviously
there's always been there's been a
dearth of JRPGs and stuff on on the xbox
from back when your back something like
Skies of Arcadia Oh
give me give me Skies of Arcadia to like
give me some Delmonico give me some
fizzy stuff okay this is what I'm
talking about
if you want something to combat destiny
your own thing to combat destiny I'm
warning you Indian
give me Phantasy Star Online 3 there we
go for a three that's call and you would
kill with that and a lot of people and a
lot of people that went over the to
PlayStation would think twice about
coming back for something like Phantasy
Star Online mm-hmm to finish - for me my
absolute mic drop moment - guy like talk
to me on the screen goes black
you see scalebound and then you see here
zone and you see : : Panzer Dragoon saga
- I was so good Oh died right then in
there because Panzer Dragoon saga is one
of the most beloved RPGs of all time I
love that game I had two copies of that
game and I made the stupid decision to
suffer and that game is worth like 1,500
bucks now although it is an amazing into
this day it has one of the most unique
amazing battle systems ever found in an
RPG um it needs to come back and if you
want to have the make something you know
make a joke of it or whatnot
and have the scalebound name live on
throw it on there and I guarantee scoop
their fantasies they're up panty dragoon
is something that would absolutely make
the hardcore happy um hello look at that
that's my pie in the sky stuff I hope
you'll show go Cal from Dreamcast fame
man listen Sega's yeah I don't want it I
don't want to jump too far ahead because
of the way they stated some things you
know they said it was a huge partnership
with Microsoft wargaming he liked some
reason why I felt it was significance
because they did include Sony yes and
Sega being a multi-platform uh you know
publisher now not including Sony not
saying they don't have Sony already but
they acknowledge of the Microsoft
acknowledgement of Microsoft when it's
me was huge
Microsoft renewing the trademark of
scalebound hearing that they actually
got the assets from a platinum which is
absolutely surprising to me I didn't
think that even they considered that
that's necessarily
it could be something where they work
was with Sega and maybe they have Sega
work on scalebound I can't think of any
other studio that would be qualified
enough to do it besides Sega in their
history but definitely bring a fantasy
star to Xbox could be huge you know that
it that is funny because if fantasy star
went on Xbox as an exclusive on talked
about more than exclusive right it's
like you got probably one of the most
loved you know Japanese games has ever
been made you can do xbox in PC Windows
10 and in that aspect you have a space
where the cross play works yes then
because now you can co-op with the PC
gamer you're playing with them you
you're really delving into something
that's like Final Fantasy 14 with their
PlayStation in PC and now you have
fantasy stall on the Xbox and you not
only have a Japanese tablet but you have
one of the most beloved animals out
there and it's very reminiscent
Dreamcast remember back in the day
dreamcatcher had that modem in the back
he got that fancy stall for the first
time and you big business boarding for
voters and you can just be online
playing fancy start with people and it
was epic so you know Microsoft's able to
recapture some of that say galore you
have an opportunity to really wake
people up like all Microsoft seg is
working together oh scalebound come back
and again this is all wishful thinking
it's not to say that that will happen
however it is interesting in what's
happening with them nice a freeman a lot
addict uh and ok
well I want to get your feelings only
Sega it comes to those Sega thing you
know I'm gonna say this and I'm probably
a lot of people here gonna like it uh I
was born in the n64 since 64 era none of
this applies to me that's all started
guys I passed it's all good listen I
respect my question to hug to you I know
this is a different perspective is that
um do any of the Sega ID's resonate with
you though like now I'm never flying on
a fantasy star really enjoyed that game
but like for the most part like it's not
that I wasn't around when these games
were out I couldn't comprehend these
games when they came and got you Sanna
Sanna Lord Lord King well you know we
are Sega babies and the fact that you
know we sat there and watch this [ __ ] we
see with the [ __ ] while it went down and
you know sad to say Microsoft is the
spiritual successor to then you know the
death of Sega to only see it rise within
Microsoft ranks will be fantastic
what Microsoft doesn't have to combat
Sonic as Sony has these games this year
that list is real featherless hashtag
haha nottingham these games and the
games are real they're coming and to
combat this Microsoft has the hardware
you know to run the better games but
they don't have the IPS and if Sega came
over and they struck a deal because the
bank vault is really big and Sega's you
know pockets of a kind of emptied it
turned out
let's fill up their pockets and that's a
service game too
let's get yeah let's get some of these
games over hill is something somebody's
IPS let's strike some exclusive deals
with somebody who's as iconic as
Nintendo
you know Nintendo's having a resurgence
let's Sega has a resurgence too as well
we're a hardwood with the hardware that
they don't need to make we could just
make games for you guys give us the
budget let's come in let's go do this
let's let's get this crazy taxi popping
Leslie you know I would love a crazy old
man crazy taxi I love it jump in with
these games Streets of Rage I was just
playing she's raced out the demo that's
you know what oh that's a great one -
exactly great one whoa you know they
have IPS that is is Ike right right now
if they were to do that like he said the
mic drop moment he walks off the stakes
a fabulous you end the show with that
sing not if you just if you didn't even
say anything about the games and and
Phil was just like I have one more
longer one more logo to show you guys
and then he puts it first like that drop
the mic moment the question is does he
literally drop the mic is he put it down
but yo all he does is just walk off the
stage if it is just a second that he
goes off look like needle if Phil comes
out and rolls up his sleeve and he has a
tattoo oh say go oh that would be
sufficient led that way we're gonna
close out with it my jobs because
obviously this is it I appreciate you
guys stayin I know we went low over he's
got a little passionate but I'm gonna
drop star settle from my job I mean you
guys are nailed it I mean for me I just
need like I said imagine a lot of the
IPS that we do know to come out look
impressive on 4k hardware
you know look great showcase that power
to Scorpio you know I would love to new
IPs to be announced you know within that
release date window hopefully of early
2018 even if they don't come out per se
at the holiday you know I would like to
see really two fresh new IPs that
Microsoft is invested in just to kind of
build confidence back in the base um
yeah outside of that I mean the
marketing deal stuff I'm not gonna get
too crazy about I think he does need he
needs a heavy hitter exclusive that we
haven't heard about I mean I obviously
heard rumors about Ubisoft and you know
if he can get me a Splinter Cell feel if
you can get me that Splinter Cell bring
that back that would be huge for me
personally with the sake of stuff you
know obviously anyone would have to say
god peace would be great I personally
love fulfilled to get involved in the
Shenmue thing it to me it's [ __ ]
that I understand that Sony has that
deal with them you know as far as
guarantor and bond they're involved all
right all I've been involved is 2015
exact all I would like us to say okay
say that if it's any way possible that
Microsoft can get involved at least a
platform version can come out you know
to that Kickstarter or whatever it is
you know to show a commitment to the
brand I would love to see that Shenmue
you know on on Microsoft's platform as
well and to me always got to do and I
know look out like I liked it but all
he's got to do is stay 400 at the edge
ok wrong I mean I would prefer dovecot
Lee I got 2x boxes I got the slim I got
the og I trade both of the men and get
the Scorpio for a hundred that'll work
I'm saying I Mason
I just want $4.99 just so I can shut up
if I gotta fight the bully buddy had a
good and I think that matter my bike job
so let the Lords get in on this or
nearby crops that would close this video
what $10 you go first
um I might drop 399 right like he said
at all that's why thinks it's a boy
back off the beginning mm yeah uh yeah a
399 that's what I said no doubt look ow
my mic drop uh national Republic 3 mm
like they're not playing on you you
playing okay Lord saw oh yeah my 3 399
and Panzer Dragoon saga 2 and Phantasy
Star Online 3 Mike said all you see is
post with your roll like a little
platform up to the stage as like a bunch
of mics on it just a little kid mic drop
cuppa downloadable right now really that
would do for you that was Matt up and
wait for this game how is that gonna do
for you when you're a tease you know
what because I could I could call home
and say yo del right now you gotta give
you smart focus you could use walk Lord
addict Mike drop I feel like a 399 Mike
truck would be it but I really like
people know that there's gonna be a
price I feel like what the mic drop is
gonna be is some kind of third-party
bill or you know I think kotor would be
the biggest might drop they can have
because people know about the prices
people know these games people know cup
heads coming out you know maybe you know
i would say a little bit more on the the
fantasy star thing but you know a lot of
people don't know what fantasy star is
and a lot of people don't know what
Couture is but the biggest speculation
right now on xbox is it doesn't have
story or teddy games and there's they're
second to none when it comes to Couture
so no doubt no doubt no doubt well it
was a great show I appreciate the Lord's
for stain a little extra long getting no
but we had the Xbox mob family edition
yeah everyone the families together
discuss these trying times and what
we're gonna do to combat them so I want
to thank our guests NorCal
- so much for coming - really appreciate
you making the time out your schedules
and Lord count we're gonna find people
find you at uh you can find us on take
network on YouTube as well as T icgn
comm want to thank everybody for
supporting us you know we're finally
getting real close to 6000 subs I know
that is a sound like a lot but all our
sides are very loyal from very efficient
is very buddy stretch license to and not
gonna knock the park RT icgn doing some
big numbers there which is allowing us
to get into these press conferences as
media so very grateful for the support
you now yeah find us on iTunes Google
Play wherever you can download a podcast
we're up on there and our network is on
here as well nice they're always a
pleasure to have Lord calendar building
and of course Lord
Tim Dogg thank you sir for coming
through where can find people find you
these days oh they can find me on
Twitter beach fire Tim dog or you can
find me on mixer mixer comm backslash
Tim dog Thank You having me really kids
you can hope you can find it all mixture
we're later on today I will be pursuing
him as Jason in the front a the 13 let's
go be photo really actually good to see
you guys again our yearly convention so
to speak se - Louis it's gonna be fun
but uh I want to get Lord attic and
there you got a lot of things going on
with these antics fat lights and shows
I'll have a talk to me so tomorrow I'm
going to have an attic show on the
Tindall in case you guys missed it I
have a Sony one and uh in a Microsoft
one I will be having a state of decay
attic spotlight probably next Saturday
it's going to be will floor Cognito and
it's going to be with again exactly like
I don't want to butcher his name but
he's he's a he's a fourth member in the
the planet planet Xbox podcast that kid
smooth starting I'm with the the Attic
show on the table the whole Oh kids move
is starting a planet Xbox pod oh that's
xbox is smoking oh na said that's not
happening that's that's that's something
that you're gonna have to talk to him
about we've got that combo about that
breath
he's gonna try to steal my Wow there we
go looks like we started a bob wall
elephant back asses fire that's a
completely different conversation
but uh you know definitely you know the
Nintendo one I have tomorrow I'm gonna
have air kiss for the win and I'm gonna
have a bland juror on that so definitely
catch that out I do want to thank you
know Kali Lord Callum Lord of tin dog
for coming I know this this podcast been
a little bit longer than you know any of
us anticipated because you know what we
wouldn't have great detail when we did
that for the viewers and you know I I
strongly encourage all of you to go and
just to follow both of these you know
these men individual yeah man they
represent a community so well you know
yes pleasure that's all I gotta say
mm-hmm absolutely Lord O Lord solve what
can the fine people find you yeah first
of all definitely a big shout out to
Lord Callum Lord Tim dog for coming on
man and whack and wax poetic with us
about the stuff that we love so
definitely ratio and the good people can
find me on xbox live at a Viet being
sovereign um PSN be XIV one word and on
Twitter at Lord saw by Opie no dumb Lord
King where can the fine people find you
sir
I like to say thank you to you know lo
Tim dog and little cow cow see you again
this year it was fantastic last year oh
I'd like to say thank you all for coming
on the show and um highlighting you know
our podcasts so it can reach more people
I really appreciate it and he told us
that then just real love and I really
appreciate it um you can you can catch
me on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
Xbox Live and place and on PSN as Xbox
360 level oh one holla ha ha no doubt of
course it's not Cognito here and I'm
like I said it's just been a pleasure
today just awesome to talk xbox and have
fun with my brethren and of course you
can find us on iTunes SoundCloud YouTube
all that good stuff we appreciate the
likes to subscribes and you know just
building this thing slowly and sticking
with us and all our day ones
much appreciated and we still the best
podcast that you've never heard and on
that note we are out but I do want to
say some record for we close out um we
will not be having an hour north podcast
next thank you
thank you for saying that much so don't
look out for we will be having one at e3
the week after that you know we're all
going to e3 so we have to figure out
some way by doing that because me will
be live streaming baby live streaming so
you know definitely be looking out for
that and you know I do want to
appreciate all the people in the coma
because that comment section was lit and
you know if you haven't like to
subscribe to the channel I appreciate if
you guys do and you know what that's
being said we will see you at e3 two
weeks table they every right this panel
will be at e3 yeah alright so yeah